this is jocko podcast number 296
with me jaco willink
the
chief of naval operations takes pleasure
in presenting the silver star metal 2
special warfare operator first class
chad m wilkinson united states navy
for
service as set forth in the following
citation
for conspicuous gallantry
and intrapedity in action against the
enemy while serving as a mission support
site team leader while assigned to a
joint task force in support of
operations enduring freedom
on 24 april 2011.
petty officer wilkinson displayed
superior guidance during a daytime
assault targeting a taliban commander
while under significant enemy fire
upon arriving into the objective area
petty officer wilkinson and his assault
element came under a hail of enemy fire
he and his teammates led his assault to
set containment on the objective area
after receiving friendly wounded
inaction from direct enemy fires and
grenades within 20 meters of the target
compound petty officer wilkinson boldly
exposed himself to the enemy and
suppressed the incoming fire that
allowed his element to move to safety
and enabled a combat medic to move to
their positions to treat a head wound of
one of his teammates
he directed two additional assaults on
the target compound and coordinated with
higher headquarters for three rotary
wing close air support missions after
evacuating all non-combatants from
adjacent buildings
petty officer wilkinson's actions
eliminated the enemy combatants
enabled the evacuation of the wounded
casualties
and allowed for the safe extraction of
the assault force
by his bold leadership courageous
actions
and total dedication to duty
petty officer wilkinson reflected great
credit upon himself and upheld the
highest traditions
of the united states naval service
for the president
jonathan w greenert
admiral united states navy
chief of naval operations
so
there you have
the award citation of a hero from one of
our recent wars
afghanistan
and war is
in some ways
timeless
doesn't change
there are heroes there are sacrifices
and there's fear and pain and loss
and war also evolves over time and
there's
new weapon
new weapons new technology
new tactics there's lessons that are
learned
there's solutions that are created
with the advent of poison gas world war
one came the advent of the gas mask
from the creation of machine guns
came the creation of the tank
war is responsible for the creation or
the advancement
of radios and radar and atomic weapons
and energy and jet engines and electric
computers and
war creates
problems
and they create solutions to those
or at least it's supposed to
there have been great advances in
medicine
from war
the civil war in america brought about
the significant use of anesthesia
in world war one
men were now being gravely wounded by
these newly developed machine guns and
they were losing massive quantities of
blood and so doctors started regularly
using blood transfusions for the first
time
world war ii
saw the expanded use of antibiotics
to fight off
infections
world war ii is also where they started
using metal plates to repair broken
bones
and fractures
from these explosions from these new
weapons and the korean war
helped advance the idea of life flights
then using helicopters to get wounded
soldiers the care that they needed as
quickly as possible
the vietnam war
we started using napalm regularly
and that brought about advances in burn
care
when they started using
antiseptic and antibiotic infused
dressings
to reduce infection so
so war creates new forms of physical
trauma
and then creates ways to help ease that
and then there's unseen trauma
the
concussive blasts
[Music]
the traumatic stress every war
has its own form
in world war one it was shell shock
and the horror of going over the top
world war ii the dreadfulness of close
killing
vietnam the
confusion over who's good and who's bad
in our current modern wars
there's something else to contend with
for our professional warriors
that is the idea of an unending war
because world war one
as heinous and awful as it was
was also finite
world war ii was similar
i mean absolute horror yes
but a horror that ended in four years
korean war lasted three years korean war
is also where we started to see this
idea of tours
where y where soldiers would go over
and do a tour
and then go home
and that was it
the same thing in vietnam
we all kind of know that story service
members were required to do their hitch
and nom
one year
count the days
and in all those cases
for a majority of soldiers
war was a finite thing
yes brutal yes horrific yes sickening
but had an end point
but many of this generation our current
generation
there's been no end point in sight
it's been a
constant
exposure to violence
concussive explosions stress deployment
after deployment after deployment after
deployment
and the training is elevated too and
that's
repetitive over and over and over again
explosive breaching of doors
firing rockets over and over again
improvised demolition shots and then
back on deployment again
and that can
become a never-ending cycle of
trauma
and that's taken its toll
on the mental health of some of our
nation's
finest
warriors
like
chad wilkinson
who received that silver star
and who finally met his end not on the
battlefield by the hands of the enemy
but who sadly
took his own life
with suicide
and we have to learn from that
and here
today to talk to us about chad and what
he went through
is his wife
sarah wilkinson
and joining her is jason mccarthy
former special forces soldier founder
goruck and a friend of saros
and together they've been trying to
share the message of mental health
remove the stigmas raise awareness
encourage people to reach out
if they need help
and encourage us all
to help each other
with that
sarah jason
thank you for joining us
thank you good to see you guys again
yeah jason came on before you're on
podcast 208
talking about your experiences
in the special forces
in florida
tennis champion
almost champion my mom was the the
athlete in the crew
um and
sarah thank you so much for coming out
it's very very awesome to meet you and
and i just want to you know get get
right into your story and the story of
you and chad
and let's let's start at the beginning
where are you from where did you grow up
how did it all start
i'm a military kid born
born and bred my dad was marine
i'm the youngest of two i have an older
sister
my mom and dad met pretty young and
got married my dad joined the military
became a marine and and set off their
path to move around every couple years
was he from a military family no
he just randomly joined the marine corps
uh
yeah it was kind of like right where he
just missed the draft but yet still felt
the need to serve i guess
he he they come from a small town in
ohio where everyone kind of just stays
in that same town so i think he wanted
to find something
bigger maybe more more challenging i can
relate he wanted to serve his country so
yeah his marine i was a military kid
moved around all the time
my dad was an officer so that means we
moved every two to three years we spent
most of the time on the east coast
we lived once overseas in okinawa
and
yeah i mean i've i went to 15 schools
before i graduated 15. so do you become
super adaptable when you go to 15
schools i guess you could either become
super adaptable or just super in a shell
and not talk to anybody i really think
you could go either way you're either
out there or you're rigid uh i consider
myself more of like a chameleon
because of that so i can blend in in a
room or i can stand out what needs to
happen
so growing up moving all the time i mean
i went to a different school fifth sixth
seventh eighth ninth grade different
school each year
for those years
so yeah
and then and so then what about chad
when did you meet chad first day of high
school
and where was this uh quantico virginia
so so
my dad marine right quantico's marine
corps base and his dad was navy his dad
was a former seal
his uncle was also a seal
so he always wanted to be a seal from
the time he was like 12. uh
but his dad had switched rates and then
was kind of on the
helicopter duty with the president and
so that's what brought him
to
quantico because otherwise i don't think
we would have met he would have never
been there
yeah we went to a really really small
school
it's a dod high school it doesn't exist
anymore so
a high school that's on base that's just
for the military kids are kids
well-behaved on the military school on
the military-based school well when i
went yes because you know we're talking
early 90s but also on base um
not on quantico when i moved to lejeune
this was the case but a lot of times you
would have a plaque in front of your
house so my house said there's a plaque
that said colonel's release
out in front of our house so you
couldn't really do too much because not
only
you know could they report to your dad
they knew where you lived so you're in a
controlled environment
pretty much yeah what kind of music were
you listening to
like grunge
you know
poppy because what year is this
well when i met him it was 91.
so you're a
freshman in high school in 91
yeah so it was kind of peak grunge yeah
you were just getting your nirvana oh
yeah
yeah he loved pearl jam yeah
yeah i still listen to it and just smile
so you guys meet
and it was a love at first sight is
there for me oh yeah
i mean i don't know about him uh yeah he
we so go into a military school right
off the bat the first day there starts
to be buzz about who the new kids are
because this kid and this kid this
school is so so small and they were
talking about the wilkinson brothers the
girls were like have you seen the
wilkinson brothers
i was like what's the deal but um
i smile because i just remember this so
clearly
sitting in the bleachers on the first
day
traditional like pe coach just like
intense call and roll and this kid was
sitting in front of me i saw the back of
his head and they called chad wilkinson
and he turned his head to the side and
he said here
and i was like oh well i'm done i like
him
and that was it
how did you connect then
well i mean a small school we kind of
you just nbn military kids i think it
was pretty natural for all of us to just
be friends there really wasn't like a
cool group and a not cool group
um
everybody you you were kind of forced to
be friends with everybody because the
school was so small and how small how
many people per
grade his graduating class was 24 i
think oh 24. that is
really really small yeah
yeah and so that's like one classroom
yeah yeah we actually the school was
middle school and high school together
it was just in a different hall so high
school took up like one hall and a half
and the middle school took up like
another hall and a half
and we didn't cross paths with the
middle schoolers but we were all in the
same building now were you guys in the
same grade was he a freshman you were a
freshman no he was he was a year older
sophomore he was a sophomore i was right
yeah
and so then
like what did he
like
say what's up sister i mean what did he
do how do you roll how did you make this
happen he was pretty cool i mean i say
there wasn't a cool group but he was i
think he was pretty cool in high school
and he was super athletic
and
i mean for anybody who's listening he's
really good looking
so
you know he had that going for him we
were just friends um the first year or
two
what sports did he play uh soccer
primarily um i think he was on the golf
team
one year and i think he was the kicker
for the football team one year because
they just
knew he could kick it you know so he'd
run out there kick and then come off
but yeah for two years we were more or
less just friends i mean in that period
of time he did ask me to go to
homecoming
um and
i was super pumped about it
so
homecoming
is what
like yeah the thing is i went to a
really small school too i think i had 80
people in my graduation i don't really
remember the home i know my because i
have i have kids too and my daughters
went to some kind of homecoming but
what's the deal with homecoming oh yeah
i know that people came to my house they
were dressed up the boys were wearing
ties and like this guy
basically a reason to get dressed up and
have a party and you know back then it
was a big deal because it's a small
school and you have a huge pep rally on
friday and there's rally yeah and we
were pumped i mean i my kids dread pep
rallies now they're like that's lame i'm
not going and i'm like why not it's
awesome
that's what we did and there was a
football game and then after the
football game
you had you had a dance and you get
dressed up and you got the like corsage
and the flower and the whole thing
yeah it's a different time
you know i was i uh was looking at a
boot camp picture of myself the other
day
and the picture was taken in 1990 right
so
i posted i was like i posted on on my
social media page right hey you know
here's me boot camp and i thought so
that's 1990
that's
31 years ago
that means when i was in boot camp if i
would have looked at a picture that was
31 years old it would have been from
1960.
yeah
crazy
and then i have
sometimes on the podcast i'll have guys
on that were in either world war ii
korea or vietnam but
recently had a bunch of vietnam guys on
and they just like they're talking about
pep rallies like these kind of things it
was just a different time i think you
caught the end of it i got the tail end
of it i think i did i think i found like
the sweet spot of high school before all
that just
blew up and diminished i don't know yeah
okay so you get a starter to sidetrack i
kind of needed to know about homecomings
because
my two daughters went to home the
homecoming thing they got picked up by
some dudes
at the house the guys were wearing ties
and whatnot
i tracked it don't worry we're good but
um
okay so you get asked the homecoming
chad yeah and and it was just the the
dance uh and then
later
well so he asked me after he got in a
food fight in the cafeteria wait you got
a food no he got in a food fight okay
he's great
and uh
he came up he had food on his shirt and
stuff and then he's like hey as he would
say you want to go to homecoming with me
and i tried not really excited but i was
like all right i was like yes
score so
yeah and we just went to homecoming and
then that was that we didn't date or
anything and then fast forward to the
following
spring
one more thing about homecoming
and dances in high school was there
particular like songs that were
repetitive because when i went to high
school
every single
dance that i went through it started in
middle school which was i guess it was
seven so seventh eighth ninth tenth
eleventh and twelfth grade every single
dance that i went to that's where we had
dances i don't know what they're called
now but every single dance we went to
every single one so there's probably
four or five a year you know six so 30
times the song that would play at the
end of the night was um was
steroid heaven led zeppelin oh yeah is
that a normal tradition is that a
worldwide tradition i think it's just a
really good march out song
they're like yeah beat it
lights are coming up
mosey out the door right on right on so
you you go to this dance and i cut you
off so you go yeah we just went to the
dance and and that was it and nothing
really like became of it but then fast
forward a couple months later towards
the end of the year
he
would go by me in the locker you know
i'd be sitting in my locker and he'd
walk by and he just hey oh hey
and i just
i kind of just did the whole girl flip
out thing like oh my god he said hey to
me
and then he needed help with a history
paper apparently but he asked me a
weekly story yeah
and so i was like okay and then he asked
me out uh to dinner i went to dinner and
we started dating
pretty much so that was where'd you go
to dinner we went to this mexican
restaurant i don't think it even exists
anymore i don't know the name of it in a
quiet harbor a little shout out i don't
know if i actually
asked a girl to dinner until i was in my
20s
well he had class well
i don't even know if i should share all
this but we actually also went to a
movie
and we bought tickets to some stupid
movie because we couldn't get in a radar
movie and then we snuck into the movie
sliver
do you guys remember that movie horror
movie it's like sexy smut movie oh and
i'm like on this date and i was like oh
this is a lot more sharon
oh i think so i actually don't remember
who was in it i mean this was a long
long time ago but i just remember being
like
completely red
thankfully in a dark movie theater
embarrassed
so yeah that's what we did we had dinner
and it's not going to rain at our movie
crazy crazy kids kids were getting crazy
i know and so what year was that was
this was his senior year or uh
i was it was the end of my sophomore
year
his junior year okay and so this was
1993 okay really started dating so now
you're legit dating yeah
through the summer well so then coming
in the fall yeah well then it was for us
i don't know if it changes but it was
like october um i have a really great
picture from that day
i i should pass it to you just because
good but um
no we my dad got stationed in lejeune so
i had to leave after my sophomore year
and
yeah and that was the only time i was
ever really
pissed honestly every move i'd be like
okay you know we didn't get family
vacations we moved
that's what happened and then you're on
a new adventure and this was the only
time i was mad and so what were you into
for were you doing sports as well i was
i was swimming
a swimmer i was a swimmer cool yeah so i
was that person that's like you wake up
at five you swim you go to school you
swim
you swim a lot yeah okay so now you have
to go to camp lejeune yeah
so i managed to work a deal and i stayed
at my best friend's house
steph cuddy
so i could hang out with her but really
so i could hang out with chad let's be
honest
movies
and yeah i just hung out that summer i
was a lifeguard at the pool on base
through high school as a lifeguard and i
pulled butts at the shooting range dang
you know like when you roll them up and
we all the high school kids we just sit
there like in this little dugout with
ear pro on and
you'd see the bullet go and you
pull the target
slap the sticker on it throw it back up
that's how we spent our weekends minimum
wage oh yeah i was barely making
anything well i mean i was actually in
the navy and i did that but we did that
for each other that's what we did we
didn't have
you know
people to come down and do it for us i
guess that's the marine corps officer
thing well our friend's dad pretty much
ran the range so i think he was like i'm
gonna make these kids do something and
so we could hang out with our friends
all day on the weekend
it makes me sound like such a nerd now
that i'm saying this i didn't do
anything like super crazy in high school
but uh we could hang out with our
friends and get paid a little bit of
money
okay so that's where you spend the
summer and this whole time you're
hanging out with chad so you guys are uh
tight yeah getting tight at this yeah or
a thing
but you're gonna bail yeah got him in
the closet
and yep so i moved to lejeune we
continue dating uh i'm a junior he's a
senior
and
he would drive down on the weekends
which was kind of a big deal because you
know he was fairly newly licensed you
know and his mom and dad would let him
drive
the minivan or what was he driving no he
had an old oldsmobile i think it might
have belonged to his grandpa
and like the front seat like was busted
so it like sat crooked
it was a hooptie it was great though and
he would drive that down on the weekends
and see me and then drive back not every
weekend but as much as he could stay the
night
parents were cool yeah this was like a
thing because
my parents my mom said to me recently
like in the last year we had some
conversations just about this chad and i
our youth and she said
i don't know what it was i just we just
always knew
that the relationship with you and chad
was just something different
and
he stayed i mean he stayed in a separate
room he was in my room but yeah well at
least as far as the parents know
he was getting tactical i'm sure at some
point
i
am
so so then how long does this
long-distance relationship work so
we and so we date and then when i so he
graduates and now i'm a senior so i'm a
senior he graduates high school his mom
and dad
move to
florida to orlando now when he's in high
school is he talking about joining the
navy is he talking about going into
teams he always
kind of
i think he just always knew that's what
he was going to do it wasn't that he
talked about it in excess so he has two
brothers he's the oldest two brothers
and then a sister
and
um
his house was just full of you know
every classic seal movie you know
spec op movie
you know he had posters on his wall
which i think i still have that you
probably can't even find anywhere
anymore but
i think it was just something he always
knew that's what he was going to do
i don't ever remember him talking about
anything else like oh i might go to
business school or something no
it was so obvious to him and you that it
was not even really a big subject it was
like yeah well what else am i going to
do that type of thing yeah and i mean
even then i don't think at my age i was
even thinking about
you know our life together like oh i'm
going to marry him i doodled his name a
lot on all my notebooks because that's
what you do in the 90s
with your grunge t-shirt and your boy
crush but um
i just always thought i'm just gonna be
wherever he is
you know i wasn't thinking like marriage
but but i just knew well wherever he is
is where i want to be right on okay so
then what happens
so we break up
so that kind of yeah so we broke up wait
so this is after oh this is your senior
my senior year so he's graduated yeah so
he moved down to florida and so the deal
was is he wanted to be an officer
and at that time so he enrolled in the
university of central florida
his mom and dad are in orlando he's down
there with them he's thinking i'm going
to go to college i'm going to get a
four-year degree and then i'm gonna go
do the whole navy
buds deal but they were saying hey we're
not really taking officers right now
because we just don't need them so you
can go get your degree but
it's not that's not gonna work out and
so
basically a year into college he said
okay i'm out
and
joined
um
so we broke up my senior year
did you break up before or after he
joined the navy before
so before so he's in orlando i'm in
lejeune we break up
really just because i think
you know you got friends that are like
why are you dating some boy that lives
so far away that's stupid and
all the things so we broke up and
um
i we spent two and a half years pretty
much
went by in that time the time he was in
college
and my senior year and then
my first year after graduating high
school
we just didn't really speak to each
other and this was before
cell phones or social media you can't
properly
cyber stalk somebody back in the back in
the day right and i would stay in touch
with his sister his little sister so
she's ten years younger than him she was
pretty young i mean i met her when she
was five so she's pretty young but um
and so i always kind of knew what he was
doing and i knew he joined the navy and
you know went to boot camp and was going
to buds and
i i really wanted to be there for his
graduation of buds but
i
thought that might be weird if i just
show up plus i'd never been to
california the whole thing i'm living
i'm gonna confirm that would be weird
yeah yeah yeah and so
during this time you know he he goes to
college joins the military i finish high
school my family moves to tampa because
my dad is at centcom
so his family is orlando my family's in
tampa i'm going to
community college and i think i want to
be there for his bud's graduation but i
can't do that so i need to put myself in
a position that doesn't allow me to do
that so i went on a cruise
and i thought if i'm on a boat
i can't get off the boat
i'm like 19 or something and we docked
we docked in new orleans and i told my
girlfriend i was like i'm getting off
the boat i'm going to go get on a plane
and i'm just going to show up there and
she's like okay and then i realized i
didn't have any money to get there
i'd spend it all in the cruise and were
you but you hadn't been communicating
with him no during this time no just
keeping in touch with his sister and
like his mom would check in from time to
time because mom still liked you yeah i
hope you know so
yeah
so then so then he graduates buds so he
graduates buds and now what happens well
i knew he graduated buds and then i also
knew he was coming back to orlando so
i took a couple days off work
and just waited
and then he called and said hey i'd
really like to see you and i was like oh
that's cool
let me see if i can get off work
you know you got to play tough
and um yeah didn't drove there um
was super nervous
his brother i think opened the door he
was wrestling his other brother in the
background probably trying to play it
cool and pretty much the same thing as
that day on the bleachers you know as
soon as i saw him i was like
man
so he he had graduated buds at that
point so now he must be on orders got
orders to a team yeah so he had to go
uh
this is when they were had specific
rates your time frame probably too so he
went to the medic school oh sorry yeah
so actually so he what he got was he
must have been a corpsman and then they
would take corman and after buds they
would take corman and send them to
18 delta the the special forces medic
school what's interesting about that and
i might mess this up a little bit but um
his dad then had orders to fort bragg
and his dad ran that school oh
so he went through the school that his
dad was running
that's awesome
i guess he got some good grades
hopefully yeah
he's a smart guy he does good in school
so uh so so then what happens so then
he's going to that school now are you
two back together is this yes like we're
we're we're back yeah back so we're back
together and this is i had 96 and so i
decide because i want to be wherever he
is i'm going to go to college at
methodist which is a really small school
in fayetteville
so i go up there for a semester i had to
do a whole presentation of my dad my dad
right colonel the marine corps he always
says when you want to do something you
better have your ducks lined up and come
to me and i did like a report and
figured out how much it would cost i got
scholarships i got different things how
much it would be paid for
really because i just wanted to be
closer to chad
was that part of the briefing or not
i think he probably understood that but
i lasted one semester i hated it and i
left i went back to florida so he did
the medic school and then he was off to
still teammate
and then what once he got to seal
teammate did you guys reconnect again
well so we're we are dating long
distance now uh he's at team eight
i'm down in florida
and then i end up going to the
university of florida
and we're thinking okay i'm gonna do
college down here you're gonna do that
and then we break up again
yeah so two two pretty big breakups
it's hard to
check into a team
and have like a girlfriend or whatever
no offense to girlfriends of the world
but when you get to a team it is like
you are going down you are
when you're a young new team guy you
have so much on your mind as far as work
goes it's like hey i don't have time for
anything else right now and i don't know
that's probably has at least a little
something to do with it you know you're
down in florida he's up there like
wanting to make sure he's good to go for
this and that
yeah we just had i mean he would drive
down still on the weekends oh you're
still dating credit then you get out
like he gets full credit yeah and um
but yeah we broke up
and
uh
that was just terrible because i really
thought that that was probably it i
thought i probably lost him forever
and then how long have you guys broken
up for
ah trying to think of the timeline i it
was probably like a year year and a half
something like that did he do did he do
his first deployment yeah he did a
deployment he was on uh the enterprise
he was on a ship only time he was on a
ship at that time and what year was that
um
probably 97
or eight okay somewhere in that right on
yeah
so he he so he does a deployment he's a
medic
yeah you guys are broken up you're going
to fl you're going to college in florida
yeah
and i'm still keeping in touch with his
sister
and
we had you know we had email so you know
like the dial-up
and i would do the dial-up email and
check to see if you'd ever email me and
then all of a sudden one day he did
and he just said i just i told the guys
i i keep thinking about you and i want
to see you i was like yes
so so do you say come up to virginia
beach did you come down to florida no i
said you know where i live
well first of all he was still in
deployment he wasn't quite home yet and
so i didn't know and i'm in college and
um
yeah he drove down and showed up at my
doorstep
and
i did the same thing
i did in high school i just
couldn't believe he was there you know
and and
just excited and we said to each other i
said to him before he comes came down
if we see each other again we're gonna
know like this is either gonna be
forever or it's just not
and he came down
and pretty much roll reversal when i
went to orlando and he asked me to stay
an extra day i said do you think you
could stay an extra day and that was it
so that was
um
uh the summer of
99 i think may of 99. how old are you at
this point
you're gonna make me do math i don't
know i'm like 21.99 so you're oh yeah
you're in college so you're a young
college
yeah girl and he's
swoops in
yeah
and says all right we're gonna do this
yeah i mean
did you drop out of college so what'd
you do no i stayed in college you're
slightly more responsible than that yeah
stayed in college um
uh
we he we got engaged that summer in july
we
got married on paper as a lot of
military people do
we actually got married up in virginia
beach in the in this guy's backyard
and
so we were at least married and had all
that
and
i spent time down in florida and then i
worked it to graduate i had to do an
internship
to finish my degree so i got an
internship with the city of virginia
beach
because i wanted to be where he was
so you guys you you you get married well
he proposes to you
and then you get married the old school
like what i did you know my wife and i
got married at the san diego courthouse
and my chief was like the wit because
you have to bring a witness so i'm like
i was like hey can you come with you
know witness my wedding and he's like
you're getting married yeah
okay so we went down there and you know
this judge goes like all right you two
are married and then we walked out and
then we went to like danny's and had a
hamburger that was the honeymoon
i'm a little bad husband
uh but that's what we did you know
that's sort of that's what you guys did
too i mean i think for me that's a
better story you know our story we went
and got married in this guy's backyard
nobody knew we were living in a house
with team guys i was living with him and
four other team guys in a house
it was just that that was some good
times at bernie's you know just uh
my poor wife my poor wife
did that too she well it wasn't four
team guys but it was me my running mate
team guy
roommate who
is just the best guy ever and also just
like insa we were all crazy and then so
we we lived in the upstairs apartment
and then two other team guys lived below
us and it was just
well i'm sure it was very similar to
the
environment you were in yeah like the
the furniture was cruise boxes uh dinner
was dominoes breakfast was guinness
lunch was jagermeister and it was just
mayhem yeah chad's brother likes to say
he remembers coming to visit and he got
out of the shower and it was so
disgusting he just took a paper towel
and like patted his body dry because he
didn't want to use anything
i mean i don't know if it was that gross
maybe for him but um you know it was
dude's house and
you know i got to live there and
and there was one giant sofa that was
the ugliest chad had bought it it was a
scandinavian print it was the tackiest
ugliest thing in in
literally his entire life he still
talked about that stupid sofa
that is i so my wife and i but my old
running mate we had this freaking couch
that was
gold uh i think it's called velvet
velvet is that what it's called like
this kind of like uh like really soft
yeah push back and forth so it was gold
velvet it had some kind of wood carvings
on the end it had to have been
more than 10 feet long it was freaking
huge we could have this yeah and it was
the most comfortable couch ever and i
think we got it at a whatever a thrift
store for whatever 38 or something best
couch ever that's what he says and we
could fit like three to four full-size
dudes on it i think it was more typical
we'd wake up and one of them would be on
the sofa just because it was comfortable
and uh they the house it was there was a
sofa and there was a kegerator that was
it in the living room
and when i told them to put decorations
up i was like you guys need stuff on the
wall they hung shooting targets
[Laughter]
like the real ones the pictures of you
know the man and the woman you have to
decide does he have a weapon does not do
i shoot him
that was when i was in our house for a
little while
yeah so you got like a heart a
really nice welcome to the team
community it was yeah it was it was um
such a different life back then yeah and
are you going out with the boys like
when my wife came over and you know we
weren't married yet but when she when we
started when she started living with me
she would like come out with us you know
and yeah
oh yeah we'd go out and
um
burn it down
i i for you know i'm in virginia beach
and there's this bar that's been there
forever hot tuna and they've since
redone it but
yeah i just went back literally like two
weeks ago for the first time and i
thought
i haven't been here in forever and it
took me back to one night in particular
chad drove a green jeep cherokee still
his favorite car always
and
we went out with a bunch of guys and we
just lifted up the back gate you know
and just shoved them in there instead of
actually you know this is a long time
ago forget the seat belt shove in there
we went hot tuna sure enough there was a
fight
we got kicked out told to leave and i
just remember
running out there throwing up the back
gate the guy's getting in and
we're out
and this lifestyle to you what were you
thinking we were like okay well this is
the way it is
yeah i don't even think i thought
anything i just was in it and
you're military and a military kid and
you understand
just the camaraderie that can happen
there and and
the sense of family that it can create
and i was
i was really happy and i think he was
too to
have made it to be a team guy he was at
team eight
yeah
yeah i um
i don't know if there's anything better
than being an e5 in a sealed platoon
it's just freaking awesome and it's
everything you just said well we so we
had a big wedding later right so we had
a wig i think for our family they wanted
like the bigger wedding
so in may
of now we're gonna go to 2000
i guess
we
got married and so the boys all decided
they were going to come and they rented
an rv and they drove
from virginia beach to where we got
married and
all my girlfriends from college had come
and they were and they're you know don't
ask a dumb question they're we're in the
reception and you look around the room
and there's one huge round table with
all these really good looking dudes
around and the girls are like are those
the navy seals
not only are they like a bunch of dudes
and they're good looking couple one of
them had like a butterfly stitch on his
forehead because they stopped in
savannah and got in a bar fight
so it was like so appropriate you know
it was good
did
when once you moved to virginia beach
he was uh he must have been in a work up
when did he go on deployment
uh
that's when i start to forget so he's
already done one deployment when he was
on the ship yeah and then he comes back
and then he did two more there
um i honestly can't remember the months
so he's going on deployment for the
first time or the first time that you're
married so it's his i guess it would be
his second deployment yeah and now
you're like what did you do did you stay
in virginia beach did you go
so this was like i had to do the whole
i lived there i did my internship then
we got really married for real and oh
that's right because he did deploy
and i moved back home with my family
during that second deployment we were in
the middle of like not living anywhere
so we lived with the team guys we had
our own apartment for a little while
and which was also one of the greatest
times because you don't realize that at
the time when you're young and you have
no money and you live in an apartment i
think it was 425 a month
pleasure house road shore drive chicks
beach like where everything goes down
just how great that is you have nothing
and you kind of need nothing
yeah it's such simplicity so anyway we
moved out of that apartment he left on
deployment i went back home to stay with
mike what are you doing here when you're
living that little apartment um
you know like what makes that so good
ah i mean there's nothing to take care
of it's an apartment
um our friend lance
vicaro who who passed away in 2008 he
lived in the same complex so you know
you shoot the [ __ ] with him when you see
him and um
yeah just like making dinner and eating
it on that we had a cruise box one of
those metal folding collapsible ones
remember those oh yeah that was our
coffee table you just put a little
like tablecloth over it we'd eat there i
was like cooking meals in a crock pot
terrible
me and my buddy had a cruise box that we
had like by the cap by the big gold
couch we had a cruise box that had the
phone on it and then on the cruise box
was in sharpie was written everyone's
like numbers from the different platoons
and like the team area number
oh yeah those are
good times i was talking also about the
as you advance in life
when you get an apartment that's like
step one but then when you get an
apartment that has uh telling my kids
this when you get an apartment that has
a washer and dryer like on site that's a
big deal and then you if you have one
that has parking that's like the next
big step up in life yeah yeah those
things are those things bring you joy
when you're young and broke yeah i've
driven by that apartment a few times in
the last two years
and all the places we've lived in
virginia beach you know
okay so you do the big the big wedding
yep and all these your girlfriends are
there from college there's a bunch of
team guys there that sounds like a
awesome time
and and and then he's going on
deployment again
uh
yeah so he
we get married
he goes on deployment
uh i think before he left on deployment
is when i found out
i was pregnant
okay yeah which was another reason like
took me home okay so
we weren't planning it but we weren't
not planning it it was kind of like you
know we've been together forever and it
is what it is
so so you get pregnant
he goes on deployment yeah you go home
to
florida okay you're home to florida and
you're
living
you know doing whatever you're doing
yeah and this again was
before
we didn't have cell phones so you know
this
it's interesting when people are like
upset because they didn't get to like
face time with their husband on
deployment
in today's world right because i would
miss phone calls and then you don't know
when he's going to call you again and we
i have so many letters he wrote me
i'm pretty grateful for that and so i'm
in florida he's deployed trying to talk
to him when i can
growing a baby in my belly
and all the things
and he comes home when did you have the
baby while he was on the planet or do
you come home in time yeah he came home
so because i was like super newly
pregnant when he left um
so we know what we're still staying in
virginia beach so i go up to virginia
beach
super pregnant with my mom and buy our
first house
while he's gone
yeah and
then he came home from deployment may
and my daughter was born in august
and now he's still at team eight
he's done two deployments
and
yeah
and it's your daughter was born in
august of 2001.
and he's in another platoon at this
point yeah
and he
so he he
he gets through his deployments and for
the rest of his time there he goes to
night school
because he's trying to finish his degree
so we finish his degree at odu
we have a new baby
and then he finishes his time uh
he was at trade okay
so we're just like a young family you
know when september 11th happens so is
he a trade out when september 11th
happens
he
was
at uh
yeah i think he might have been actually
yeah
and so september 11th happens now what
are you thinking
ah that's such crazy
everyone remembers where they were when
that happened
i don't even think i had the ability to
think about it in the scope of the
military and what the military was gonna
do or our country was gonna do to react
i just was dumbfounded kept trying to
call him at work couldn't get a hold of
him he eventually showed up at the house
and we just kind of looked at each other
and he's like holy [ __ ]
so
and at that point did you was he like
okay i'm gonna go back on deployment was
he
what was his plan at that point
i mean i think his plan was to just stay
he at that point i think he always
wanted to just be a career seal so
whatever was going to keep him in the
game quite honestly we had a
conversation after a deployment and that
he wanted to go to damn neck
and i was like no
um
and
i don't even know why i said no i never
said no i always like supported him and
encouraged him pushed him but for some
reason at that point i didn't want him
to go
um i don't know how it would have turned
out if he would have gone then but
yeah so he
he stayed in the military but then
because in all this when he came home
from that last deployment i
got pregnant with our son or his third
deployment at eight and
uh that was when so 2001 but fast
forward you know we're in 2004
and
i think we both
kind of well i would say it's more me
we wanted something different so chad
wanted to be a seal he always wanted to
be a door kicker that's what he wanted
to do you know hide in the bushes and do
all the things and as military kids
i was really trying to do something
different and the grass was greener on
the other side right i moved all the
time and i didn't want my kids to have
to move all the time and i didn't want
their dad to be gone all the time and so
we talked about it and we were making
the decision to get out of the military
so he had been in 10 years at this point
and
it's 2004
his son is born
he
wrapped up that last deployment and we
got out and moved to raleigh north
carolina
do you know where he went on what did he
go to iraq or afghanistan on that
deployment or do you do a different
deployment like over to ucom or
something
uh i
i should know these statistics and facts
better but i don't i mean i'm like 23
with a baby and yeah well this would be
very similar to asking my wife
where i went on deployment she'd be like
i have no idea he was gone
that was my wife's attitude too yeah
yeah he's gone uh he'll be back later
yeah
so
so you all make this decision to
to get out right
and then what's the plan
so
at that point his family's now living in
raleigh north carolina and he's he has
his college degree
he's done 10 years in the military and
he thinks okay i'm going to get out and
i'm going to provide for my family in a
civilian world and
and that's what we did and he got a job
in pharmaceuticals you know there's a
lot of research there
um
kind of irony in that when i'm sitting
here thinking about him and his life and
the path that he chose but
he was in pharmaceutical research and
we just
hated it
from the moment we left
i think most people are creatures of
habit it's my belief right people are
creatures of habit whether you like that
habit or you don't like the habit it's
it just is what it is and our habit is
that we are military kids we are used to
adversity and challenge and changing
dynamics on the regular we're used to
different situations and the idea of
living in the same house
doing the same job with the same people
for the rest of your life as nauseating
and i don't think it was challenging for
him and while he did one of his last
jumps with the guys before he left
the guys jumped out of the plane and
they're like you're not going to do this
with your pharmaceutical dudes you know
and
i think i think that always
bugged him and
and i think like most of these guys they
don't want to feel like
they quit i guess
and for chad anyway
separating from the military and not
retiring he probably felt like he wasn't
finished
and i felt that too because he was
miserable he was miserable we were
miserable how long did it take for
buyer's remorse to set in like when you
get to north carolina that was there any
sort of like honeymoon period hey we can
go on a picnic today and we don't have
to worry about anything oh yeah yeah how
long did that work
i mean
i think it lasted for about a year
even though i think in the back of our
minds we'd lay in bed and we're like
he'd say what are we doing what are we
doing like out of the gate yeah really
yeah at night you know but then it's
like okay we're we're doing it though
because because at the same time you see
it as a challenge in some ways you're
like am i doubting myself because
i want to go back or am i doubting
myself because now i just have this new
challenge and i gotta like overcome it
and what was he doing for the
pharmaceutical company he was a project
manager
and
i think he was eye candy for all the
girls in office
i know this because my sister-in-law
works in the field too and she would
tell me stories but um
yeah he tell i just
he said to me
i he came home and he's like sarah
i was sitting in the break room today
celebrating a baby shower eating a pink
[ __ ] cupcake
and i'm questioning my life
and you're like okay i don't think this
is going to work and
as cool as it is to have him home every
day and he had a good job we made good
money the american dream i mean our
house had a wrap-around porch no joke
the picket fence i mean
by by most standards
i don't even know if that's fair to say
any more in today's world but
it was the quote american dream but
it was not our dream how far into it was
the cupcake incident was that like two
months into it no that was closer
towards the end that was probably about
two dollars like the cupcake that broke
the camel's back totally the pink
cupcake broke them
i think it just was a real
pivot point and this isn't to bash
cupcakes or baby showers or any of those
things but
yeah he's just a
he's a dude you know he's a military
dude he's a knife carrying
you know
dude and for him to put on a business
suit and a tie every day
you just
people shouldn't be things they're not
and that's not who he was
so what was the total time that he he
made it in the pharmaceutical so he left
the military in 2004 and we were back in
the military september of 2007.
so like two and a half two and a half
years yeah what when he
like okay so he comes home from the
cupcake incident
or you just like
you can see the misery in his face and
you're like all right i'm good let's go
yeah
yeah i
that um we also i mean i remember being
in the living room and in hearing about
red wings and us sitting in the living
room and watching it on tv and just
him just he you know he was just sitting
there he kind of had his hands on his
head and he's holy [ __ ]
i think that probably had a large part
even though we didn't come back for some
time i think
those things weighed on him
the way the world was changing it was
ramping up we're now a couple years past
9 11.
he he felt called to go back
then he makes a phone call talk to like
some
guy or whatever and team guy recruiter
or something yeah we didn't really know
how that was going to play out right i
mean they could have just said no you
left but i think at the time you know he
he you know he was a team guy that done
a few deployments he had good service
respected they said sure
but they told him because he hadn't
deployed in you know almost three years
he had to go back through
um
oh sqt well it was stt when he graduated
sqt channel
so
we i mean he left for work one day
he had talked to this guy and was kind
of figuring out if this was going to
work or not and he left for work one day
and i just said
his tie and his suit and all i said this
is stupid we got to go back and
we sold our house and
and he signed up to go back and
we sold
a lot of what we owned
and because there was no need to have it
we we were going to move to california
he he said if he had to go back through
sqt again he wanted to just go to a west
coast team
just so we could all be out there
together
and we put a little bit of things in a
u-haul and the kids and i flew out to
san diego
and i had never been there oh i came out
and like house hunted trying to find an
apartment for us a couple weeks prior
but other than that i hadn't really
spent any time out here and and he drove
a u-haul cross-country chowing down on
sunflower seeds and just going like 90
and
like
you know jacked up on caffeine and
and got there
then where did you guys move into did
you guys move to coronado yeah we found
this cool little and just got lucky
found this cool little apartment same
thing kind of like our first apartment
it i mean this place can be more than
800 square feet it was two bedrooms one
bathroom
it was our entire bah maybe even a
little bit more and our kids shared a
room
did you say you had been to san diego
before or you had not i had only come
out like a week or two before to try to
find a place to live
um what were you thinking when you drove
from san diego over the coronado bay
bridge and you see coronado first i was
flipping my lid i just was like yes this
is amazing it's one of the craziest
sights
i think when you when you bring anyone
to san diego and you go to coronado and
you drive over the bridge and you just
see coronado yeah it's it's ridiculous
it is it's ridiculous and i've spent you
know i spent most of my youth on the
east coast and
and
almost always close to a beach i always
you know i don't want to live more than
30 minutes from a beach let's be honest
so the fact that i could flip coast and
and live here and on coronado is it yeah
and there's no mosquitoes here yeah i
had a friend coming out and and him and
his wife and
like it was getting to be dusk
and they were like oh the mosquito's
going to come like there's no mosquitoes
here they didn't believe me they didn't
believe they didn't understand what are
you talking about how could there be no
mosquitoes
it's totally yeah crazy
so
now you're living in coronado yeah
kind of living the dream taking bikes
around the sidewalk walking to get
coffee and all that stuff oh yeah i got
a rad little beach cruiser chad bought
me and my kids were little and
um my son learned to ride a two-wheeler
at two
and he had this little mini bike and we
made friends with the guy in the bike
shop and his name's hut my son's hudson
and hudson would ride in the bike shop
and one day the guy's like hey little
man come here and he swapped out
i should show you a picture of this he
swapped out at the handlebars of his
bike for ape hangers oh damn so he was
like he turned three and he was a
three-year-old with this like little
mini bike and he's a hanger handlebars
it was great
and chad's going to sqt this time so sqt
just so everyone knows it's when you get
done with buds you go
you graduate from buds and after buds
they start to teach you some stuff in
this thing called sqt you don't really
learn anything in buds
other than how to go through suffering
and then you get to sqt and they start
teaching you
like all the fundamental basic
individual skills of being a seal at a
higher level and occasionally like
chad's a perfect example guys guys out
for three years hey we got new radios
uh we need we can't just throw them back
in a platoon all right send them through
sqt so occasionally that happens it
happens sometimes god doesn't even have
to get out if a guy's on shore duty for
three years and he's been
in some billet where he's not
operational for three years they'll be
like hey you know you go back through
sqta and usually guys look cool yup got
it and so you're doing individual skills
but he
in that position
all the other guys first of all the
other guys don't even have their
tridents yet so he's a actual seal yeah
and they're uh
they're
just not even new guys yet because they
don't even they don't have their trident
so he's in a position of
like real mentorship and to help them
out and they're looking up to him so
that's
that's what's happening with him
definitely he
one thing i always
loved about chad is
he is very good at teaching you what he
knows without making you feel dumb
i think he gets a lot of that probably
from his dad and the way his dad is but
um
i think that that's a real skill and and
try to like foster your own learning
while he's teaching you something and so
i think it was a really natural fit for
him while he was in sqt
to just be the guy that would you know
lean into guys and say hey man this is
how i like
rig my gear up this way and i you know
do this this way and
i think it was a good
experience hopefully for the guys that
were with them you know to have this
more senior person around but it was
also good for chad
and this didn't you start doing crossfit
at this time out here oh yeah
yeah and
was that andy's gym andy stump yeah so
the reason i'm i'm laughing is because
you know you're talking about how
chad was the type of person that could
teach you something without making you
feel
bad about what you don't know i think
andy might be the opposite of that andy
like enjoys if he's got to teach
somebody something he teaches me stuff
that i already know he makes me feel
stupid
yeah
definitely so you so this is andy had
like a crossfit gym in coronado yeah
yeah and so you just rolled in there and
signed up did you know anything about
crossfit at the time so when we were in
raleigh chad started doing crossfit this
was like 2005.
and
he was so into crossfit i was so not
into crossfit that's kind of how that
played out i remember cooking dinner one
night and he said you need to come in
the garage i got this thing called a
muscle up and i was like oh and i opened
the door and he did it and i was like
cool and then slam the door like a total
jerk
so he had put me through some workouts
in our garage in raleigh but i
minimal exposure you know and living in
coronado and having two little kids and
he's busy with work
and i feel like you know i'm a mom with
two kids i probably need to exercise a
little bit more riding my bike one day i
just passed the gym and it was new it
was like
literally like just opening and i called
him didn't know andy stump at the time
called him up and said hey can i come to
your gym and
that was it that was it was he teaching
not as much his wife uh
jamie was teaching a lot
sage castro dave castro's wife was
coaching there some right on it was it
was such a you know these are the early
days we're talking
um
of you know of crossfit gyms kind of
expanding and so it was a small gym not
a lot of trainers yeah this is so
like this is when dave castro was
teaching
sqt
and like i think they ran a level one
course
yes
at sqt and i went and went through it
and just like hung out and got whatever
some kind of certification for that and
then that's that's probably the first
time that i met and started hanging out
with dave castro i think that's it
because he was running that and he was
like helping me out and then we
eventually well when we opened this gym
that we're sitting in right now
that was two thousand that was late
2007. so
we had the um
you know i had to go to like the certs
and stuff like this that you have to get
yeah back in the day yeah
keep your potential to keep your gym
yeah to keep your gym and
so you get you get into it you kind of
get into it yeah i do i get really into
it um
i just you know i like the challenge i
like the physical challenge i like the
way my body was changing
remember i'm a mom with two kids so
uh
yeah i get into it and so i got the
opportunity to go to my level one
didn't want to coach people ever never
never my plan i just wanted to know more
about it so i went to my level one in
san diego one weekend
yeah
okay and then chad what's sqt six six
months something like that yeah yeah and
he's thinking west coast team yeah
you're living the dream living in
coronado yeah and then what happens
there
well
bill king happened uh
the ceo from damn neck came to the west
coast to talk to the sqt guys and
to explain to them
down the pipeline if they want to ever
you know
bridge that gap and head over to seal
team six here's kind of what you need to
do
most of those guys when they finish sqt
as you said they get their trident they
go to a regular team they've got to do
two to three deployments
you know become maybe a little less
green and then they can screen to go to
damn neck
and that's when chad went and took it
upon himself to introduce himself to him
and say hey my name's chad wilkinson
here's a little bit of my story i'm
going to finish this up i'm going to go
to a west coast team and then in the
future
i plan on coming to screen and he just
said how about you don't and just come
screen right now
that was that yeah and he didn't consult
me at all
but that's okay so would you get six
months in the notto yeah that's just
about it i was pretty upset i mean
but not right i mean this is our life
and this is our path but
i did not want to leave yeah he came
home and he said hey i'm gonna fly to
virginia beach next weekend and do this
thing to screen and if that's the case
we're moving
and yeah fast forward we moved back to
virginia beach april 2008.
did you move back there even before uh
like while he's starting to go through
green team and everything oh yeah yeah
we moved like with him like he left to
go to green team
we moved back
so then he makes it through green team
and starts the the cycle over there
which is deployment deployment
deployment workup deployment work-up
deployment work-up deployment work-up
deployment i mean at that time yeah 2008
it was uh
fast and furious
it was busy
and when you get to virginia beach are
you
what'd you do with your crossfit deal so
i moved back to virginia beach i check
out there at the time there were only um
two other gyms in the area
and i couldn't really take my kids
because
this was before there were a lot of kids
spaces and crossfit gyms and there was
really nowhere safe for them to be we we
rented an apartment when we came back to
virginia beach not knowing where we
wanted to live
and also not knowing if the whole green
team thing was going to pan out i think
for chad he just was like i don't really
know
and he rented a garage in this apartment
complex and we bought enough equipment
so that we could put two people he and i
essentially through a workout
and then my girlfriend said well can i
come work out with you and i was like
sure
and
then that just kind of grew and grew and
then we had a whole bunch of people
outside of the garage one day and fast
forward october 2008 i opened my gym so
he's in green team and anybody who's
listening and has lived that is
very stressful
um
especially when you know you're you're
coming you're doing all these things and
you come home and you got your wife and
your kids and you got to do the family
man thing too and then i go ahead to
take it upon myself to start this whole
business venture
yeah
you rented how many was the space that
you rented for that crossfit gym oh the
first one yeah
it was like 12 to 1300 square feet
and
i i just remember saying to him in the
car i was like i need to do this because
this is this is about to take off and
and this is all i want to do
[Music]
i think he was a little worried because
you know in our work his world you live
a really
quiet life
and
he didn't want anything that i was doing
to
not overshadow but
have any sort of imprint on what he was
doing yeah you know and for sure and of
course in a military town
the heart the interesting part about
owning the gym is what you're doing is
you're providing a service to people
and
it's a very personable service so people
think they know you and what happens is
your friends come and join the gym and i
had kind of established at the very
beginning like we're friends but at the
same time this is this is a you know a
business
and you do if if your team life you
don't talk about it in this gym
you don't i don't want to hear when your
husband's coming home i don't want to
hear when your husband's leaving i don't
want to hear about another spouse
that just wasn't going to fly
so
so we were busy
with two little kids and how did the gym
take off how did it do it went it was
awesome uh my whole hope was just to be
able to
cover the rent and my expenses and we
exceeded that the first month the first
month
and uh
we were still working on a lot of things
though you know the first person that
came beyond my kids and they had a
little kid i didn't know what to do with
them so i stacked up some tires and i
just stuck the kid in the center of the
tires
i'm like just stay there until we're
done
because it was such a small space i look
back at those pictures now oh man
anybody from crossfit listening and i do
not know how someone didn't get clubbed
in the head of the barbell how close we
were
but it all worked out
and meanwhile chad's
like you said this is now 2008 so it's
just um it's on yeah
and he and he's going on deployments and
now
we kind of already talked about this and
i mentioned that my wife would be like i
don't even know where my husband's at
he's gone and he'll be back later that
was kind of her attitude and it's i
think
quite frankly well i can't speak for
everybody but it definitely worked for
my wife you know she just
hey you go do what you got to do i'll be
here i'll be here man in the fort back
home
and that was good maybe it would have
been more stressful if she knew where i
was or what i was doing or anything like
that she just was like you go do what
you got to do
did you guys have that
was that sort of the way you guys
operated yeah i mean when he
when he was deploying it was iraq
afghanistan
then it became africa and i knew
generally you know what country he was
in but beyond that that's how we always
operated was
you do your job and and i'll do my job
meaning take care of our kids when
you're gone and when you're gone you're
gone and when you're home you're home
i know some other spouses they share a
whole lot and they they know probably
way more stories about their husband
than i know and and maybe almost too
much but
chad really
really lived by the fact that you don't
talk about it and and it could have much
to what you said maybe he just didn't
want me to worry either that's what i'd
like to think
um
and and vice versa i didn't call him and
say
you know i mean my hot water heater
busted one time in the attic and it's
flooding everywhere what's it going to
do if i call them and
no so you
you know seal wives are tough too
they're yeah definitely and i i think
you know you said i don't you you said
you weren't sure if chad didn't want you
to worry i can almost guarantee you that
the attitude was like the last thing he
wants you to do is worry and i remember
uh
one of my guys mikey monsoor who
you know he died at the end of our
deployment but when when i got home and
talking to his family and
his his sister sarah
was you know
just telling me
this was we were in this uh place called
ramadi it was a really
uh kinetic deployment with a lot of
casualties
and
he had told his family you know when he
would call them oh yeah we're just you
know we're just training some iraqis
we're yeah if we're not doing anything
it's boring like all these kind of
things i mean these are just outright
not true at all
but he just didn't want his family to
worry about what he was doing yeah and
we had certain like code things i knew
when he would call me and he would say
okay i'll call you when i can and i love
you it he was going out he was going out
to do stuff and i you know would he call
me in a day would it be three or four
days i don't know but i
i knew that meant he was gonna be busy
and i'll also say like from my
perspective again this is just me
but
i don't want to talk to my wife about
that stuff you know i don't want to talk
to my wife i don't want to explain to
her what's going on with this and what i
don't want i don't want to talk to her
about like what our kids are doing or
what we're having for dinner or whatever
i want to talk about other stuff that's
what i want to talk about i don't want
to talk about team guy stuff with my
wife that's not
so maybe that you know plays into it too
and
yeah i mean my like i said my wife would
she would barely know where i was going
or whatever and it's partly because i
didn't want to worry yes but also i just
don't want to talk about other stuff
yeah
talk about work
you know 19 hours with these dudes i
want to talk about it with you darling i
want to talk about something else
uh
but at some point you must have realized
or did you start to see like hey these
things are wearing on chad these
deployments are
like was was there a change in his in
his attitude and his personality in in
the way he carried himself
uh
yes and no
i think it's hard to distinguish
when exactly that was and and i'm gonna
bounce around a minute i just had to
scroll through a bunch of photos jason
and i were working on something and
through scrolling through those photos
the other day what i realized is
when he really got bad it was two years
before he died
so 2016 i can almost see it through
photos
but even before that um
i do
know i know some stories now since he's
died that he never shared with me and
2012 was a pretty
big deployment i guess or crazy
deployment i don't know the best way to
say that
and i think some stuff happened there
in 2014
he was starting to change a little bit
more but what a spouse says
is
well that's just how they are and
the the the world the media
talks you know navy seals are big in the
news now right
since 9 11 since may of
2011. they're all over and they're made
to be larger than life and they use
these words and and so
if a guy is always told how brave and
fearless and heroic and strong they are
then he's got to believe that he's got
to live that and then on the same token
you see with our special operators how
they are
you know
quiet and how they do sit in the corner
of the room and their back is always you
know to the wall and they're always
facing the door and they don't want to
engage in conversation all the time and
just chalk up all those those
ptsd symptoms that people like to throw
out but it's i think it's very easy for
someone like a spouse to say well that's
just kind of how the guys are because
they have a stressful job and they're
beat down their body's broken
so so you said when you're looking at
pictures
now and you're going through the years
you can kind of start to identify
things that you saw your that when you
look back it becomes a little bit does
it become more obvious as you look back
yeah yeah i mean i i couldn't tell you
then
but it's uh it's more obvious to me now
this might be a dumb question but do you
think that that has to do with
the fact that we don't get taught
anything about this kind of stuff we
meaning
and and maybe it's more prevalent now
but
you know um
i i did a a a couple podcasts on here um
about um
lewis puller lewis puller junior he was
the son of a famous marine the most
famous marine named chesty puller and
lewis puller was um
he was he his dad chesty puller
was
like the the most iconic marine ever
and he received five navy crosses and he
the
here's a good way to describe how iconic
he is he uh the marine corps has a
has a uh
what is it a mascot
and they've had one it's a bulldog
and yeah the mascot i think they're on
number 17 but the mascot is named jesty
and at boot camp they sing
uh good night chesty wherever you may be
that's what they do in marine corps so
this guy chesty pulled the most iconic
marine of all time and he had a son
and his son was
uh
not quite cut from the same cloth as his
dad you know his dad was this kind of
gruff guy and this son was sort of a
more mild guy
he wore glasses
he went to college
he
uh was just more of a cerebral type guy
he gets done with college and he's not
really sure what he's going to do with
his life
so he
decides well you know my dad was in the
marine corps go join the marine corps so
he goes to join the marine corps he can
barely get in because his gla his
eyesight's bad
the people that are looking at his
application are like wait a second this
says lewis puller junior are you chesty
pull her son he said yep no but we we
can get you in so he gets in the marine
corps
goes through officer candid school goes
to the basic school and then it's
1968 so he goes to vietnam
and
when he gets to vietnam
um
going on rotations in these three
different spots and
eventually uh goes on an operation and
he steps on a land mine gets severely
wounded he loses both of his legs
he loses a bunch of his fingers and
dexterity in his hands
almost dies i mean it's just a miracle
that they were able to keep him alive
and he he
he does stay alive um
comes back to america
you know devastating for his dad
the great iconic marine hero is breaking
down when he sees his
son chesty puller um lewis puller you
know eventually recovered from his
wounds
and uh wrote a wrote a book called
fortunate son which is an incredible
book
and and sort of you know he was he'd
gone down the path of alcohol and
being an alcoholic and all this and and
um
eventually comes out of that
writes this book the book gets published
and
in 1994
he fell out of his wheelchair
injured himself went back in the
hospital
they put him on painkillers he got
addicted to painkillers again and
and he killed himself
and
what was
when i when i did this series of
podcasts about this what was crazy was
every single marine every single marine
knows who chesty puller is
but
a vast majority of marines that i talked
to as that podcast was coming out did
not know
the story of his son
and
it seems like the perfect way to educate
people
about
the
hardships that people face when they
come home from war and they you know
obviously lewis puller had a multitude
of hardships as well
but it seems like the education that we
receive
and not just us in the military but then
the families
that there's things hey this is what we
need to be looking out for
and
it it seems like if you're if you now
are looking back at pictures
to be able to say man
i see this i remember this
these are the kind of things is this
like like part of the
things that you're trying to share now
so that people have better education
about this kind of stuff oh my gosh yes
yes yes and again i'm no scientist i'm
no doctor
i don't have research under my belt but
i have what i've lived and
sitting in my chair
having been with this person for so long
you know we we i didn't just like meet a
team guy and then we got married and
that's not to bust on anybody that did
but you know i've known him almost his
entire life
and then to watch him through his career
and then
to lose him in this way
i didn't see
all these signs and symptoms prior
i think if chad
i want to believe
that if chad thought something was wrong
with him that he was probably trying to
hide it from me
i have other girlfriends widows whose
husbands took their life and they have
said that their husbands expressed to
them the struggle they were having and
what they were thinking about and you
know
their signs and symptoms and i didn't
have that
and it's not going to be the same for
everybody we're humans we're all
different whole biological dna it might
express itself differently but if we
could maybe
educate people a little bit more
about the toll your service takes
and um
and to know that even if you're not
killed in action or killed in training
or you don't die by suicide but you've
led a very
active career you are going to be
impacted some more than others and let's
really have a conversation about what
you might see and when is it going to be
really pro when is it really a problem
so as these deployments are adding up
for chad
i mean is when he's coming home is it
are you what is the kind of things
you're noticing
uh
well that he's he was always super quiet
guy
never the loudest guy in the room
um
reserved
but as time goes on
he's even less
and when we first you know a teammate we
hung out with people and had friends and
when we first got to the command we did
that too and then over time we just
didn't we didn't do social things i mean
we almost never
ever had anyone over to our house ever
he never wanted anybody in our house
he
he and he says he likes to be home he
like to be home with the kids and i kind
of what you mentioned he's like i'm with
those dudes all the time like
i don't need to go hang out with them
because i've just spent you know
a rut trip in chicago with them and i'm
home now but it it
what got really bad right away was
asleep
and i i think that that's true for a lot
of the guys
is that
you know sleep is so valued and it's if
you think of your body i like to think
of it as a computer and if you don't
turn the computer down every once in a
while and reboot boot it it gets jacked
up right doesn't run well and that's
what sleep provides all of us every
single night and
if you've got a guy
who has his body hurts i mean chad fell
off of a ladder
um pretty high up and jacked his back up
he messed his neck up off of a couple
landings that he did he was in the
helicopter crash in 98. um
so you know i mean his body he
and i say this because i know so many of
the guys are like really broken and and
and he's probably the least of it in
terms of broken bones and this and that
but his body was beat up as most of them
are and then you add on top of that
just
the mental strain of war
just deployments
you know sleeping over and some
shitty ass
village compound
you know you're listening to blasts
coming in
uh
the high cycle of just like missions
going out going out going out okay being
away from your family and even though i
didn't call my husband and say hey this
is broken or i need this
maybe maybe that's how other spouses
communicate so now there might be stress
because
they got
[ __ ] going on back home with their
family and
so let's all add all that onto it and
now let's add at least for our special
operators
the whole blast injury concept and
the guys that have spent time and i'm
gonna talk teams because that's what i
know but
time in the teams the last 10 to 20
years they 100 percent
in my opinion are affected by blast
injury because it comes from them
breaching doors which they do not just
overseas but in training you know helos
rpgs all that and that constant impact
to the brain is
terrible
it's terrible and
so you've got all this stuff this guy's
gone through and he can't sleep
he can't get a good night's sleep so
there's nothing helping him for his body
to at least try to recover something
so his sleep went down bad is he is he
seeing doctors or anything is he talking
to anybody about trying to get sleep i
mean sometimes you know at some points
they were giving away uh like the sleep
potions like it was nothing oh yeah i
mean he he did he tried to do a lot of
his own stuff just like normal regular
remedy stuff and better sleep hygiene
and then he was diagnosed with sleep
apnea which a lot of them have so they
have a cpap machine i mean why are there
dudes
in their 30s and 40s with sleep apnea
doesn't that weird and then and you know
and then what you also see in these guys
is they get low testosterone
and
because of you know their adrenal glands
are jacked up their cortisol levels are
jacked up and so their testosterone is
jacked up
and i don't know how many of them are
really willing to talk about it but i
think there's a really large number of
dudes in special operations that are in
their 30s
that are on testosterone
and they're they're not i can't speak
for everyone i mean i don't think
they're on it for like they necessarily
want to be jack they're on it because
their t is really low and
that's needed you know
oh yeah let's not get fired up yeah so
so you're seeing all this stuff um
is there is there a point where you
start
like trying to intervene yourself or is
chad just like you know i mean again i'm
comparing this to my
experience like i would never my wife
didn't know if there was anything going
on like with bad things were happening
at work my wife would not know well and
this is where like regret comes in and
just kind of
um guilt a lot of guilt
because it's really easy to sit here now
and list all the things i could have
done to be a better wife
[Music]
but at the time
i
chad and i
chad and i are both the type of people
that
we want to
work really hard at what we do and we
want to be really really freaking good
at it
and
being married to him while there are
spouses and they choose to to whatever
their route maybe they work maybe they
stay home with their kids everybody gets
a choice right and my choice was to work
and go this whole fitness crossfit path
so when you're married to someone who's
this navy seal and does all these
awesome things and gets these awards i
was super proud of them but i also
wanted my own identity and i wanted my
own success
and and a lot of that driving force
truthfully
was always because i wanted him to be
proud of me
and so he's working hard and teams and
i'm working really hard on this whole
crossfit side
and i
i don't think it's that i
didn't want to intervene i just kind of
thought we both were
almost like handling our [ __ ]
if that's fair to say like okay you're
working you're busy
you know you're moving up
um
you know within your troop and squadron
and the whole thing and and i'm doing it
over here and then we come home and we
take care of our kids and
i guess i just didn't take enough
responsibility for that
is there is there some point where you
say okay this was sort of
where you said you said when you were
looking through pictures you said two
years before you died you were like yeah
i look back now and that this is a time
period where there was definitely
he he was you know over the edge yeah i
mean he he really got a shorter fuse for
sure
and it generally wasn't with me it
tended to be more with our kids
he would just snap which was really out
of character for him and
he would not listen
and
i think a lot of spouses say you know my
husband doesn't listen to me or my wife
doesn't listen to me when i'm talking
but he it it's like he had no idea i was
talking to him and i'd be sitting right
next to him and
i've shared this story before but i
think it really says something that he
i said chad you never listen to me like
just look at me i need you to look at me
and i need you to focus
and he said you know what when you talk
to me i have to look around and think
well that's not going to kill me and
that's not going to kill me
and i remember thinking that's so weird
but now
i realize if you're kind of in this
hyper state
and you don't have a way to get out of
it you go on deployment and you kind of
have to stay on point right head's
always on a swivel even maybe when
you're in bed you got to be ready for
the next thing how do you turn that off
when you come home
i'm not sure
[Music]
i'm not sure they've really figured that
out so they come home and they're still
kind of like
overloaded
and that's something that you notice
because you're talking to him and he's
like not responding and
yeah and and in the pictures two years
prior in the pictures when i look at it
he just had a completely different look
on his face it was almost like
like in pictures it was almost like i'm
gonna kill you you know like that whole
like
it just
it's just not like him
yeah that's the the interesting thing
that you pointed out is like you've
known him since he was whatever 15. yeah
and so you see this entire arc of a
human
whereas you know if you
if you cut out if you met him
in 2010
you would see this much smaller picture
that maybe wouldn't paint such a
dramatic change in the way he in his
character and the way he acted
right but you saw him since he was 15
years old
and
you know um and then you see this this
whole story play out and so it becomes
real clear
they're also being said
since you're with him every day you know
you're you're around him all the time so
there's also that that thing where
you know you don't notice that someone
you know like you don't notice that my
hair is going gray right because like my
wife doesn't she might notice it now
but
you know over time she's not like oh
your hair went gray today right it's
like happens gradually over time and so
there's some of that i'm sure at play
too where
you know one deployment there's three
degrees of
change right the next deployment there's
four degrees of change the next
deployment there's five degrees of
change
okay so you look up in six deployments
and that little bit each time you may
not notice it so dramatically but from
the the amount that he's on a different
course mentally is dramatic
yeah and and i
i try to take it back through chunks of
our life and and go back as far as our
childhood but more like when we were at
team eight how he was with his fellow
teen guys and peers and the way that we
interacted with them and then when we
got out of the military the way that he
was and you know we had friends and did
all the things normal couples and
families do and then
coming back and and then being at the
command for the first couple years it
was that way and then slowly he just
did less and less
socially he was a little more cut off
and then as it got farther along he just
was a little quieter
and
you know the last
year or two of his life
i'm
sad i'm like gosh i don't even know how
much he smiled
yeah
and no um
no know him saying like hey i gotta talk
to somebody
no
which um
and i mean i i'm guessing it's changing
now but i mean that's the culture from
buds
from basic seal training don't go to
medical
right don't go to medical don't talk to
anybody if you got a stress fracture in
your leg let it break don't go to
medical hobble around as long as you can
don't like that's
and again it's not like anybody tell you
of course what do the instructors say
yep go to medical check in if you got if
you're feeling but the the culture is
and it's the same in every unit it's
it's every units like this i mean and
it's special operates every unit it's
every unit in the military
suck it up
don't say anything don't go to medical
hand like you said handle your [ __ ]
yeah i think the guys are just too
i i i i don't know what they think i
don't know if they think maybe this is
just me like what's up with me am i
[ __ ] up i don't want to tell my
buddies i'm might be a little [ __ ] up
or
they don't want to hurt their service
or they just want to ignore it and hope
it'll go away they think they'll just
like
muscle through it
i i don't know what they think
but somehow we need to shift the needle
a little bit
to recognize
you do all this training i mean millions
of dollars
are spent on these guys you guys to
train millions of dollars and and you
know i mean chad was a sniper and
free fall jump master and you know name
all the things
and you took the time to teach them that
so why wouldn't you take the time to
also
teach them about maybe some ways that
they're going to be potentially impacted
after multiple years of service
it's 2021 and right now what we're about
to see are people that have served their
entire career post 9 11.
so this suicide epidemic
it is not going away it's only ramping
up
yeah
you know when i when i kind of started
off talking about this
that that's the connection that i made
as i was like listening to your story
hearing it
is you know we've made all these
developments and all these different
wars from the
problems that the wars cause right
and yet and i didn't even talk about
like the
like these current wars the prosthetics
you see the prosthetics that people have
now they're amazing you know they can do
all these incredible things and we make
these massive advancements and yet this
is just like over here in this dark
corner
not not really being addressed
now i i take that back there is there
are there are things that are happening
now that they are starting to address i
know that they're doing like baseline
studies of guys i don't know what you
know about this stuff jason but they're
doing like baseline studies
uh brain studies on guys so they can
kind of tell where they're at so they
can see what kind of impact they've had
over over time so i think maybe it is
starting to come to light a little bit
now
uh but
certainly i don't think the culture
has a big change to it yet because
i mean it's hard it takes it takes time
and effort to change culture it would
crush the recruitment process wouldn't
it
we've known for years because of history
and wars that when you go serve your
country there's a likelihood you could
die
you're choosing to serve
and die potentially by your flag
but it would really crush recruitment if
insert
army navy
whoever and you say hey
you want to be a seal you want to be a
green beret you want to be a and you say
you're going to come you're going to do
your service you're going to do cool
[ __ ] you're going to jump out of
airplanes you're going to shoot guns and
you're going to kill bad guys and if you
make it by the end of it you might also
have some pretty severe mental health
issues and some brain injury are you
good with that
i you know it's hard for them to pony up
and say that because oh man is that
going to crush our number
i think people would still show up for
that
i mean it's like because everybody when
you when you do this you're you're like
well that's not going to happen to me
oh i know i mean i i other guys not me
i i did the keiko form before every
deployment and i was fully
prepared as you can be
as a spouse
in the world we were living in i mean we
attended many funerals in those last 10
years
that my husband might not come home
and if he doesn't come home he's going
to come home in a coffin with the flag
over it
that's not what i got
so where does it where does it go
towards
towards the end what are you seeing
towards the end
one of the biggest things was
well he started putting on weight and
you know he would joke because he was
over 40 and he's like you don't love me
anymore because i'm
getting heavy which would never be the
case but um he started to put on weight
but what really started to happen and
and pretty drastically i would say the
last six months that i can look back now
is he got really puffy
his face got puffy almost like
this sounds terrible like have you ever
seen a fish in water it's dead and it's
kind of like bloated that's how his face
got
and um
and i
he also as weird as this is i would
always kind of kiss him on his temple
and he didn't smell the same
and
i thought oh that's weird well i've
learned
since then
a lot more about the way the brain's
affected and
to go back to that kind of
systemic derailment when you have a
blast injury
uh you know you it's it's a wave right
that goes through the air and basically
your brain
shakes up inside your skull and that's
what it's built to do that's why we have
a skull and that's how it's made but
it's not made to get that over and over
again so when that happens
and there's swelling in the brain
it then starts to affect everything else
because the brain is connected to the
rest of your body and and you see where
not only hormones get derailed but um
you know your your metabolism gets
jacked up so the guys start to
gain weight and when your metabolism
gets jacked up it also messes with the
ketones in your body
which would be like you know factoring
in with your urine and different things
and that's what changes the way they
smell
and the puffiness is because well sure
if he's got brain injury and there's any
swelling or there's just systemic
swelling in the body it's got to go
somewhere and so we start to notice it
in the face
and
again i didn't know any of this stuff
prior and and that's not to say someone
listening you you're sitting there and
you look over at your husband you're
like my husband's face is puffy
but
there's something to be said that
ptsd is a genuine thing i believe i also
believe it's overused
a lot
and this is is a whole step further
than ptsd
well and also you're talking about
it's it's it's not just
hey your face is puffy we have an issue
no it's this this this this this you add
all these things together and you get
that many red flags yeah then that's you
know you've got the the being short
tempered you've got the hey uh you smell
different hey you're not talking hey
um
you know you're you're not working out
as much as you just start adding all
these red flags together and it's like
okay
you know we have we have we have to
address this
well and and
when you think about the different parts
of the brain you've got your your limbic
brain your monkey brain deep inside
that's what tells you what's safe is
this dangerous this is why we don't walk
into the street right we know that's
dangerous
the prefrontal cortex kind of is
how do i feel about that
so
if if the brain is affected that's when
we see them you know the short fuse how
do i feel
i'm angry
i'm aggressive maybe i'm sad different
emotions but when it's brain injury and
we've heard cte right punch drunk
nfl players our guys get it too
our guys are getting interface astral
glitter scarring and that's almost like
think of like a
ricochet
almost bullets through the brain and
that's what comes from the blast injury
and that's able to penetrate
that deep monkey brain of like is this
safe for me that's why guys make
decisions that are really really bad
whether it's you know drinking too much
um
infidelity or you know i have a friend
who
he's good now but he
had his daughter in the car and had been
drinking and was
speeding well far
above
the speed limit any father would know
none of that is good
but he wasn't able to make the right
decision
so
yeah so i started to see
looking back i can see how how he had
changed and and i
i've shared with jason to
chad
climbed mount oconcagua in january
and
of 2018
and that's that's the second highest
summit in the world it's the highest uh
in south america it's in argentina and
he went and climbed this it's a little
over 23 000 feet
and
i will never know
but i do believe
that him climbing that mountain
exacerbated
any of
his brain injuries that he had
and i've since talked to
um
a doctor who i respect highly she's been
studying blast injuries in kosovo
soldiers since the early 90s or at least
that's who she started with
and i asked her about that and she
you know again she didn't test chad's
brain but she was pretty confident that
that was probably the case too
yeah i mean what how long was that
that's got to be uh a couple weeks at
least of a three of an evolution yeah
and it's lack of o2
highly strenuous
yeah and so now you've got this brain
that's injured we what what encourages
uh healing in the body blood blood flow
right you have surgery okay cool you
need surgery once you get up we want you
to move your knee because we got to get
blood flow to it because you want it to
heal right brain's injured wait now i'm
going to go up 23 000 feet and i'm going
to be without the oxygen it really needs
to heal itself yeah one of my um
um the guys go through the hyperbaric
chamber right which is just o2 pressure
o2 it's the opposite of climbing a 23
000 foot mountain and it provides a lot
of healing
a lot of healing to guys so to have to
do the opposite of that i mean it seems
i asked her about that and she said
i said is that something that would help
and she said yes but not initially after
injury i mean we're talking different
things because you're talking about guys
have been back for a while and
we do see people who have
a little bit exacerbated symptoms at a
higher elevation my best friend's
husband they live in colorado and i said
to this doctor i said what would you say
if there was a 20-year
navy seal
veteran who's done upwards of probably
10 deployments
without a doubt probably does have some
some brain blast injury
and lives at eight to ten thousand feet
and before i could even finish the
sentence she just shook her head no no
she just kept shaking her head no and
she said bad bad very bad i'd tell him
to move
what was chad's uh
like debrief points on the on the
mountain climb what do you what do you
say about it
he said it was really hard
really hard um
i think he was really proud of himself
for doing it but when he came home and
walked in the door i mean he was so
skinny
just
you know would he lose 15 20 pounds
probably um
and he came in and he just said baby
that was that was really freaking hard
and
i just didn't really ever hear him say
that about anything and i was like oh
well you did it you know good job and
he
said denali's next
that was his plan
and when was that that was in january of
2018 yeah
and how about the interactions like with
the kids at this point the family like
is it
are you noticing more is it is it um
plateaued out
um
well at this point it's we have
teenagers and i remember saying to him
they don't even want to like hang out
with us or be home or anything and he's
like i didn't want to hang out with my
parents when i was
17.
uh
we did take a family trip that june of
2018 we went to the grand canyon and
again
i look back at those pictures
and
he definitely was not there
like he wasn't on the trip you know what
i mean
he he was obviously there
but
we we stayed in a couple different
cities we kind of jumped around arizona
for a while and you know we're staying
in this really nice hotel and he didn't
want to leave the room
you know it's granted it's june in
arizona so it is very very hot but
you know you didn't really want to come
down to the pool
you just want to sit in the room
and you're like okay but we're on a
family vacation and
um
one time he was sitting down by the pool
and
i saw him from a distance and he just
was kind of like leaned over in the
chair just like
zoning out just he was just not there
and i said hey i walked up i said hey
what are you doing he's like
nothing
just yeah just things like that he just
wasn't
i don't know what he was thinking about
so where's it go from there
well
and in the timeline yeah yeah so he um
he
this year in 2018 i think is when it
started he switched squadrons so he was
moving around
within the command and
he
he had said that he didn't think that
this is what he was supposed to be doing
i remember him saying i just i don't
think this is right i don't think this
is really the path i'm supposed to be on
and again he didn't really share a lot
with me
and he and i said well
you're someone who's always accomplished
every goal you've ever set for yourself
you make a goal you go do it so he had
this goal for himself
he had
was in the process i guess of attaining
the goal
and
i said maybe this is just the first time
you change your mind like you just don't
want to do it that's okay you can you
can decide to change your mind and he
was like well they've spent so much time
and and money on on doing this and again
he didn't tell me any details and he
said he goes i know i'm not really
telling you much but it makes me feel
good to talk about it and i was like
okay cause if he's gonna talk i'm gonna
listen
and
um
[Music]
yeah so something was bugging him and i
don't i don't know what but something
was really bugging him and
the beginning of october he
started hanging up his awards and things
in the house which he never did before
so we had you know like a lot of guys
all
plaques and awards and he has a silver
star and maybe marine corps medal and a
bronze star and
all the things
and we had them all framed years ago but
he never hung him up
and he just thought it was really weird
to hang that stuff up in your house
because he said what's someone's going
to come in the house and it's just like
look at me
and
i always thought that was weird that he
had to struggle with that but
yeah he hung him up in our stairwell
to our house so
maybe like you and your wife marriage is
a compromise right
and i thought you know almost no one
comes in our house anyway and if someone
were to come in our house only they way
they would see him as if they went up
our stairs basically to our bedrooms but
in my mind i just thought well
at least he's hanging him up so they're
not going to get like broken or busted
or anything and
he talked about hanging a somali flag
on one wall which you would have seen
when you come in the front door
and
i just remember thinking that's so weird
and i thought he was really messing with
me
and when i turned around to kind of
laugh i realized he was serious he was
dead serious
and he's like yeah i guess that's that's
dumb huh
and i was like well
maybe
i i asked him if he was okay i i
remember kneeling down in front of him
and i said are you okay
and he said yeah i'm okay
but
there
if there was any sort of
like first feeling it was like
he's off
i would have never thought three weeks
later he would take his life but that's
what happened
so
it's interesting and while i i won't
share her story
i
my other girlfriend
will tell you
who knew that her husband was struggling
about two months prior
there was just like a a switch
two months and he was gone
so for me i think it was three weeks and
he was gone
i think they just meet this like
threshold and and i don't know how we
figure out where that is that's going to
be half to left to scientists
but but there is some threshold that
happens and and then the switch is
flipped
and is he still going to work i mean
this
you kneel down in front of him you say
are you okay
he says yeah do you buy it
um
you want to buy it i did buy it and and
this again is a is one of those
post-death struggles
um when someone takes their life you
military or not
you are left with so many questions and
i think that's
that's that's the beast
to not have answers
and
i believed him because
there is nothing i didn't tell him
so i believed
that
if there was something he needed to tell
me
he would tell me
and then he goes into work yeah
he went into work he had a he had a work
trip the week before
this is when it gets really weird so he
had a work trip and he could drive there
and he was supposed to come home on a
friday
and he called me on a thursday they had
used rental cars to go up there and he
said hey i'm coming home early
can you
pick me up
from
the rental car place wherever and i was
like oh okay
and
pick him up
he
we had to take her i had to go get my
son from a football game so i drive him
back home and he instantly comes in the
house so chad had been doing had had a
concealed carry license and he'd been
rolling with a concealed carry you know
when he's home around town for probably
the last year or two and again
i didn't really think much of it because
i mean well crap he's a team guy and
and this is america so
um we come home and he instantly goes to
the safe and gets his gun and i said it
was just kind of frantic and i said you
realize that we're going on a school to
pick up hudson he said i'm not getting
out of the car
and i it was very like short and i was
like okay
so we go no big deal i and the whole
time he's in the seat he's just like
he just seemed uncomfortable um
i learned later
that and i i don't know any details of
whatever he was doing but he was in a
course and he withdrew from the course
he never quit anything
he never like stepped down from anything
i'd ever known
so
that conversation about i'm not sure i'm
doing what i'm supposed to be doing that
came
later that night
when he got home and
um
this was on a thursday and on friday i
had to leave to go
i was working down in raleigh i could
drive there for a seminar
a crossfit seminar yeah and we talked
about it
that he needed to call his doctor
because he felt like
he just needed to check in like maybe
his testosterone was off maybe something
he's like he wasn't feeling good earlier
that week he told me that he had some
headaches
and like some stomach aches he had said
he didn't feel good which again chad
never said i mean
i don't know if ever he said i don't
feel good i mean he didn't say it like
that but he would never say that to me
but he did he didn't feel good
and so the deal was when i left he was
gonna make an appointment with his
doctor and he was gonna make an
appointment to talk to his boss about
whatever his work situation was to try
to figure out what his path is going to
be
and
i left i told her kids hey you know
dad's kind of stressed out just
just so you know he's got a lot on his
plate right now and when i left i'm
leaving virginia beach and i just had
this like gut and like
pit in my stomach like i just felt like
i shouldn't be leaving him
but i did and went to raleigh worked
talked to him on saturday
um
and on sunday kinsley called and and
said that dad's acting really weird and
he's just laying on the landing
and he's just staring at the ceiling
and
i just
that's just weird
that's just weird and
i was four hours away and i had to work
still a full seminar and
i just knew i had to get home so
the seminar finishes and
um i get in the car as quick as i can
and and try to race home and he called
me at one point and he just said i love
you
and i kind of laughed and i said i love
you too
and he's like no i mean i really love
you i love you so much i love you so
much sarah
and he knew i loved it when he would say
my name
and
i said you know i love you too but can i
call you back i had a really bad
headache
and honestly i was just really trying to
get home
so
fast forward a couple hours later i get
home and
i go in the house and
he's upstairs and he's rummaging below
the bed for something and i come in and
he turns to me and
i hug him and
kiss him and
he kind of just like
like
collapses in my arms a little bit so i
just hug him for a second and
[Music]
i i just think in my mind well i'm home
now so i'm near you and i'm gonna
try to just
i didn't think at the time that i needed
to necessarily keep you safe
i thought i just had to keep you close
and
and make you feel better
[Music]
so i got i had to get a shower and i
said come talk to me while i'm in the
shower and when i went around in the
bathroom to start the shower he wasn't
right behind me and i looked out the
door and he had just like collapsed like
face first on the bed kind of like the
letter t like arms out to the side his
head just to the side like like just
exhaustion
and
i said what are you doing come on come
in and so i get in the shower and he's
sitting on the bathtub
and he's just had bent over and he's got
his
hands on either side of his head and
he's holding his hair and he's kind of
like gripping his hair and i kept saying
what's wrong you know what's going on
and
he got to talk to me and he just kept
saying i don't know
um
anyway i asked him to pass me a towel
and
he looked at me and he he was
not he wasn't there
like his eyes were just like i was just
like looking straight through his eyes
and
i just laid down with him in bed and i
just thought if i could keep him next to
me then
then he would feel better
but that wasn't the case
so
i woke up in the middle of the night and
he was standing there
dressed
looking out the window and i said what
are you doing
and he just said i don't know
i said well come lay back in bed with me
and he did and
um
the next morning
early
i woke up i i woke up to see just him
walking out the door i saw like the back
of his shoulder
leave leave
and i i
it's like i couldn't talk
it was like i couldn't get up i don't
know if it's just because i was sleepy
or what or i wasn't really processing
like oh he's leaving right now
and then i couldn't find him
so i woke up you know a little while
later and he i couldn't find him
so
i
looked around and i thought well maybe
he went for a walk maybe he went for a
run maybe he went to go get coffee i
tried calling him he didn't answer i
texted him he didn't answer
um
and
went round in my head trying to trying
to figure out where he could be i got in
my car at one point i thought i'll drive
around and then i thought where am i
where literally like which direction
would i drive what's happening i thought
well did he leave for work he was
supposed to leave on a work trip
but i figured he was also going to talk
to his boss so
you know did he go to work i just didn't
know
i called his dad
um but because he was so weird the night
before i just thought it was weird that
he left and he didn't say bye he never
didn't not kiss me goodbye never he
actually
would do this i'd be upstairs and he'd
say okay bye i'll see you later and he
would slam a door in the house just to
see me run down
furiously down the steps because he knew
i would get so spun up if he left and
didn't kiss me goodbye
so
i don't know what i was thinking i just
know
i wanted i just wanted confirmation of
where he was
and i finally called the command
and i talked to the psych there
and
she asked me a bunch of questions uh
one of the questions she asked was how
does he feel about
and he asked
he said chad's boss's name and i thought
that was a really weird question
um
because
another thing i really loved about chad
is is he really never said anything bad
about people
so
you know if he liked you or didn't like
you i didn't really know he just that's
that's how he walked and
i was like i have no idea um
but she
she just kind of let me think he's on
his way to work you know like he's
probably left and is on this training
trip and a little while later i had
talked to her again and i said you know
everything's here his toothbrush is here
his medicine is here his sunglasses are
here
he wouldn't leave with all that stuff
and she told me
due to the privacy of his job it would
be likely that he wouldn't be answering
his cell phone
and i said okay
so
like the wife that i was
i kind of just thought
okay so he must have gone and it was it
was a driving trip up the coast a little
bit so i thought okay he was supposed to
be back the next day
and
so
i think about that and my kids came home
from school that day and
they said where's dad
and i said oh i don't know i think he
left on this work trip he should be home
tomorrow and i'm saying that almost
feeling like i'm lying because i don't
believe it but i'm trying to believe it
because
that's what i was told and
and why wouldn't you
right
so this point you know he disappears
monday morning probably i'm saying
somewhere between three and six a.m
and
monday goes by we started demolition on
our house we were doing renovations that
started that day and tuesday comes
and
i went my house sits near a lake you can
see it from my front porch and i went
for a run
and and
this is why i'm sharing it'll make sense
in a minute but i i went for a run and i
ran past the lake down the bike path all
around and i was gonna sit at the lake
for a minute it's the end of october
it's virginia beach the weather the
weather was really beautiful that day
and
i was gonna sit on the bench at that
lake but i didn't
because i wanted to go inside and shower
and like curl my hair and look nice for
when he got home
so i did that
and
dropped my son off at a friend's house
he was going to play
going to a football game and as i was
pulling back in a psych from work called
and said
ma'am your husband didn't report to
muster
we're heightening the alert
and i said that's bad that's bad that's
very bad
and i pretty sure i hung up the phone on
him and when i got out of my car so now
where my car was
it's um in this cul-de-sac nearby and
and it's facing that lake
and my house is on the left and as i'm
walking up to my house the head
contractor for the renovations comes out
and he says miss sarah there's two
police officers at your back door
i
i called my best friend courtney
her husband and my husband
were in buds together
and i said
you need to come to my house right now
and i just hung up the phone
and
i didn't know what was going on i just
thought
something is like seriously
and i went in my front door and out my
back door the way the house is and there
were two cops in my garage and they were
we stood outside the door and they said
um ma'am do you know where your husband
is
and i said no i can't find him and i
haven't been able to find him and i
asked him if they could move farther
down into the street because we were
right
underneath my daughter's window and i
knew that she was upstairs
and i just didn't want her to be
i just i just didn't know what was
happening um
so we moved out into the street
and
this cop just
opens his door and he like dig something
out of his car and he just turned me and
he said
ma'am i'm really sorry to tell you but
we found your husband and he took his
life
and i was all alone
so
right about that time
court courtney pulled up
sorry
i'm sorry
courtney pulled up and
i think i was screaming
and she bear hugged me from behind and i
think we i pretty much took her to the
ground i think
and she said you don't know that so she
screamed at him you don't know that
well he'd taken his life at that lake
and he could see her house from where he
was
at least that's what they tell me
so
my daughter's upstairs
in a room by herself
and she can see and hear everything
and my son is at a friend's house
and i'm pretty sure my neighbor went to
pick him up
so he told my son
so
um
i
you have to understand like logistically
speaking there's a lot of things that
just don't make sense
where my car was
when i got out of it and that guy said
the cops were at the back door
if they had just found his body
i didn't see anybody over by that lake
it had been like 36 hours
since i couldn't find him
we went back later
and i and i do think he was at the lake
and this is why
we went back later and in our
neighborhood so many people have
cameras on their house
and there's footage of chad
and the bike path
that lines that lake
uh if you walk to it it kind of tease
and if you go left it takes you all the
way up to the main road
that the cars go in and out of the
neighborhood
and i think we've we timed it so that
cameras caught him walking that way
and that would have been right at the
same time he would have watched our kids
leave for school
so
when um
when when this is happening when this is
getting like
when when
when he leaves in the morning and you
you start thinking like where is he is
there any part of your brain that's
thinking
he could kill himself no
so well i take that back
i did ask
chad's dad
i was trying to get into the safe
um
so i guess i guess there was a part of
me that did but
this he this was a little farther on in
the morning so when i first couldn't
find him i just couldn't find him but
then after a while he i think it might
have been his dad that said have you
checked the safe
and so it took me a minute to try to
remember the combo
and i got in there and
to my knowledge all the guns were there
but apparently they weren't
i guess the reason i'm asking you that
is
because i don't know various
conversations in my i've had in my life
with various people at various times
and the conversation is something like
you know
you know that little exploration of wait
i'm worried about him
and then there'll be some kind of an
explanation like
what do you mean well i'm just worried
like
he might kill himself
and then the conversation is
he would never do that
right so that idea of
we think we know we think we know what
someone's going through we think we know
what's going on in their heads and
i think that
we don't know we don't always know
and
you know like um
he disappears you know like what that's
what i was just thinking like what was
that in your head of like hey you know
what he's
you know he probably is going to see his
parents or he's you know going to go
freaking surfing or whatever he's going
to do
but this crazy idea that
he might go kill himself
it seems so
unbelievable
you know um for someone that's like hey
he's been through whatever 10
deployments he's done all this he's done
this he's done that we've got kids we've
got a house we've got all these things
going on all these good things going on
in our lives
that's not a that's not going to happen
and it seems like oftentimes
people are caught off guard by it
people are caught off guard and i know
you mentioned a couple of friends where
there was
real signs of you know hey
not things aren't going good for the
individual but all but a lot of times i
hear it's like
you know there's been some suicides in
the seal community where there was
no indication at all
at all of any kind
and and
it seems like we're conditioned to sort
of not even think that it's a feasible
thing
i
guilt
you know i i was just as bad as
as
the military makes
the guys out to be
because as i said in his funeral
to me
chad was unbreakable
i mean
to me
he had done all these really
amazing things in his life
he
he's
you know he everything he did he did
well everything he did and
seal you know
great
ridiculous high gpa when he's going to
night school and he has a wife and a
baby and
really good in sniper school and
went and got his project manager
license certification all that in the
business world and
whatever fill in the blank
climbing mountains
qualifying for the crossfit games like
insert whatever
he just was so unbreakable to me
and and i guess
that's part of my
what i want people to recognize with
your person
is that
they are their navy seals but at the end
of the day you're just dudes
you know your dudes and
humans and
with a heart and a conscience and
dads and husbands and brothers and sons
and
um
not unbreakable
this is um
a book written by a guy named david
hackworth who is a vietnam korean war
veteran and one of the things that he
talks about is the fact that like people
are different right and as you mentioned
people are different and some things
impact different people different ways
and he described like there's a cup that
people have and and
when it gets filled up with like the
stress and the trauma
once it overflows like that's it
if you if if it overflows that's it like
you you that's it and different people
have different size cups and some people
got a freaking five gallon jug and some
people got a tea cup and and everything
in between
and i i compare that to another uh
war veteran dick winters who is the
character of band of brothers you ever
seen that
but he's got a book about
about war as well
and
his big thing was like
when that cup they use a different
metaphor but
when the cup starts to get filled up you
need to get the person out of the
situation and if you get them out of the
situation
the cup like
the the water will
dissipate and it'll go back down and
they can continue they can go back they
can continue to perform their job but
same thing if you let the cup overflow
then
it it's it you can't put the water back
in there you know i i always talk when i
talk to people about this kind of stuff
i talk about the check engine light in a
car right if the check engine light
comes on
you take it in for a service you you
stop driving it
and as long as you take it in for a
service and it gets some downtime and
the engine cools and you put in fresh
oil whatever
the engine is going to be okay
but if the check engine light comes on
and you just keep running that engine
you're gonna burn that engine out and
you you'll destroy the engine
and
you know i think that all these things
come into play and that's what makes
this so difficult is
everyone's just got a different size cup
and everyone's got it you know a
different time that their check engine
light comes on and how much it's going
to take to get that thing cooled back
down
and it makes it it makes it so
challenging
to universally say okay well here's the
limitation that people have so i think
what you're doing
talking about how to identify that
check engine light so
people can see it
and then
also trying to help people to recognize
that you gotta kind of you gotta do your
best to see your own check engine light
and when that freaking thing comes on
you gotta do something about it and if
you don't do something about it you're
going to blow out the engine and then
you're no good
yeah and and
as we've said a couple times that the
guys don't want to worry the spouse or i
say spouse or first responder like who's
who is your your go-to person right
they don't want to worry the spouse but
if i were to ask
someone that was struggling right now
maybe they're sitting there and they're
there they've thought about taking their
life and they say i don't want to bother
my spouse i don't i
i would it would be better for her
if i wasn't here and and i can't speak
to the relationships that people have
but sitting on this side of it
sorry i'm like a total crier today
he didn't even give me the chance to
help him
that hurts
so
it it's on one hand you can say well he
didn't want to burden you you know he he
just
he didn't want to
cause you any worry but i mean look at
where i am now
did he not think
that this wouldn't like devastate me
forever
he didn't even give me the opportunity
to like try to help
you know jacob the hard part comes in
when
you've got
guys
who
you're bred not to talk about this stuff
you're just constantly bred and the the
interesting part for me in this journey
of learning
chad's story and my wife emily and i
getting to to know sarah and her family
really well and going really into this
issue
is
there's actually something that happens
to your brain right it's this is not
something where
it's not like oh you know
i'm i've just got this this inexplicable
weakness going on because that that's
what it is in the teams right it's like
oh that dude's weak if he goes and does
this
and you know but if you if you blow your
back out or if you you know you get shot
or if you do you know things that are
acceptable injuries
you know by just
by team room standards of sorts right
and the thing that's that
it's like my best friend in basic
training killed himself
and i didn't unpack that at all
right i mean his dad was a general
and that was something that in my
training it's just i you know i couldn't
sit and and
think about this at all it's like days
of thunder right when
you know cole gets
tom cruise gets injured right i mean the
injured driver goes way over there and
nobody ever wants to be around them and
for me personally i had to just kind of
take that and say all right i have a job
to do and he was weak good friend of
mine and he just that's that could
happen to him
and there's something what i told myself
was
there's something that he was born with
that made him do that and this just kind
of brought it to life and when you hear
chad's story if you think that you
didn't hear the story
because you know that's the word of
caution to to the guys in our profession
and to to millions of americans out
there right the
this idea that
you're born with this or you're not i
mean
situation brought this brought this out
right it's chronic stress chronic pain
going on from injuries and and just the
way that you train the way that
i mean it takes its toll
and and then that leads to all sorts of
things and you know the brain is
something that we don't really study
that well we don't study it much at all
and you know it's one of those things
where we're able to
you know cure this virus almost a year
later with a huge national surge because
because we give a [ __ ] that matters and
this is something that is just kind of
still floating around over here i mean
what's it going to take
we're losing our some of our most
valuable
people on in our country right to
something that we just don't understand
but what i know my mental shift is to
say there wasn't one bit of weakness in
chad wilkinson there was something that
is inexplicable that we just have not
explained yet that that changed inside
of him and some decision-making process
you know
it just it changed
and we have a long ways to go
yeah there's a famous football player
from san diego a guy named junior sayo
have you ever heard of him oh yeah like
the most beloved uh
probably san diego charger maybe even
the most beloved san diego athlete
total stud you know a beast of a human
like a super nice guy he was just just
this incredible human being and he
retired from the nfl and
he killed himself like he had everything
and you know that that that
made me think of this
you know sarah when you're like talking
about chad and
when i've talked to people that
like are are depressed
straight up depressed
their heads and in like this their heads
in a storm their heads in like darkness
and and
it's really like from the outside
you look at them and you think oh yeah
well hey man it's you know you're in
this bad situation but it's only
it's only just right around you and if
you come over here a little bit you'll
be out of the storm like come on over
but from their perspective no matter
where they look it's like
darkness and they just see the storm and
they don't see that if they can move
forward more they can go a little bit
further and they don't see that
everybody's on the outside going hey
like it's okay man it's super sunny and
bright and if like there's a rainbow
over here and everything's cool
just just just move over here a little
bit and they can't they they don't see
it they don't see it they can't see it
they can't see it because it's there
that's what that's what's around them
and so like
it just causes them to do things that
don't make any sense to us because we're
looking at them from the outside going
hey
like no it's sunny it's sunny and they
can't see it and it's
like trying to convince people
it
it it's almost impossible it seems
almost impossible to try and convince
someone
that that storm that they see
360 degrees around them thunder
lightning winds that's what they see
and to convince them that hey man right
over here
it's sunny and it's nice beach day and
it's 80 degrees and we're gonna it's
okay
they they can't see it
and it's so hard to get them out of that
cloud
and i think that's where people get
stuck
and it's so frustrating from the outside
because
[Music]
we can see all that other good stuff
that they just don't have the ability to
see anymore so i think it's like a
combination here you got like i said
junior seau
what better life
could that guy have set up for himself
you know he's got
everything that a person could want
and yet he's in this cloud and it it
consumes him
i mean so did chad right i mean exactly
a great family great life he had respect
hit honor
and we had everything it doesn't get
better than that right i mean that's
that's the the currency
when you're in that line of line of work
you just want you want to be respected
and and you want them to think oh
he's doing a good job and you know
you look you look at where he went and
what he did he had that and when you
can't see it there's there's just
something there's something else going
on
absolutely and and so when when you kind
of look at that i mean you know
it's like what's the responsibility
moving forward right i mean there's some
command responsibility i'm not sitting
here pointing fingers backwards i'm
sitting saying like you know part of
what we want to do is is educate the
next the next crop and i know you're
huge on this as well and
i mean it's the hardest thing
to do sometimes is to take someone out
of the game it's like you know we
started this in football you've got the
concussion
measurements and if you get a concussion
you got to come out
and you know if it's your star player
he's still got to come out
and and you start to look at like how
are we doing this in the military you
know we kind of say the military is not
a social experiment because it's not but
the the truth of the matter is is that
when you get into these
especially units like devgrew and delta
and sf right i mean your job is to go
win wars
i mean this this is not
like that requires i mean the american
alpha male is is a very special
kind of thing in the history of history
and it requires a special
type of training it requires all sorts
of things
that that make it very difficult
to to stop them
from wanting to keep
going after that you just you it's like
we're breeding it into them it's like
you take american alpha males and you
make them more alpha
i mean it's
it's quite impressive and you create
these units i mean they're storied units
i mean devgrew steel team six i mean the
seals
it's these are these are
you know it's very impressive and so how
do we
how do we how do we protect the guys
though
and i say this from a two-way street you
know it's one thing to hear and say oh
you know
we got to know that if we're not
sleeping well that there's something
wrong and that's going to be a problem
like okay i'm like i'm on a team i'm
like yeah got it right take another pill
right work out a little harder maybe
i'll sleep better yeah good you know
and it's like that's not going to work
right it's not going to work it's at
some point we have to we have to put
more
of a systematic approach in here to
mental health we've done that in in sf
right i mean they're starting to treat
green berets like professional athletes
which is great you know you've got a
locker room you've got you know the
physical trainers you get physicals you
get checked up you get all these things
and
you know if we don't then it's
too much of the loss is in vain yeah
yeah no and
they they definitely are moving in that
direction in in the teams and the seal
teams like the the baseline studies that
they're doing they are they are
absolutely moving that direction i mean
they have whole
organizations within the organization
that are focused on that
and
um
yeah i mean their
lessons have definitely been learned
that's great i mean chad
chad killed himself three years ago yep
like that we're not moving we're not
moving fast enough
i mean the the va you know what the
budget is for veteran suicide prevention
it's 10.2 billion
wow that's a big number that is a big
number right and you know the va gets
just [ __ ] on all over the place right
the va is actually trying i mean if you
look at budget there's some trying there
they're trying experimental stuff
antidepressant nasal spray right
virtual reality-based suicide prevention
training i mean these kinds of things
like they are there are things that that
we are trying we as a nation
and
it it's
at some point you know
the guys that are close to the guys
and and gals i don't want to i don't
want to exclude the the
female service members either because
this affects them as well i mean you're
you're actually statistically more
likely to commit suicide if you did not
deploy than if you did
explain that again so
if you did not i mean it's saying you
know like just because you were on seal
team six or just because you saw intense
combat
right
that that's not a predictor of suicide
so it might be a predictor of you know
tbi and those kinds of things because
you know if all you do is explosive
breach charges next to doors all day
long i mean you know commanders
have to figure out a way to limit that
stuff like you can only do this so many
times i got it you don't want the first
one to be on you know the the house down
range you have you have to work with
live explosives
but but at the same time you can't
you can't just go through the same
repetitions a million times and
you know i mean the other part is you
you have your your team time and you
roll off a team and there's always guys
behind you
and and this is credit to america first
off and credit to just who we are we we
sign up and we say send me
and and there's a lot of us that answer
that
when you're on that when you're living
that life and you're on these
deployments doing this cool stuff you
don't want to miss any of it
like this is my slot nobody's coming in
behind me and you know sarah you told me
this you're like you know and the truth
of the matter is there's there's a lot
more seals right behind you
and so commanders have this at their at
their discretion they have this this
ability to kind of how do we
we can take a look back now right remove
all the politics about you know the wars
are ending well the wars aren't going to
end for the tier one units ever right
but at the same time we have an
operational
we're not there's less going on there's
less work and we have this ability to
kind of reset a little bit the way that
we're the way that we're approaching
this
yeah yeah well uh this kind of
conversation right here
this is a thing that can hopefully move
this in the right direction and i know
that's
the main reason that you're sitting here
today
um is to try and move this in the right
direction
um
and and you're actually let's talk about
how you're doing that let's talk about
you know the actual
charities and stuff that you guys are
doing to try on ways to raise awareness
yeah so uh the one thing jason and i are
partnered on is the workout in honor of
my husband we refer to it as chad1000x
again i spoke about this at his funeral
as he prepped to climb that mountain he
did it by doing step ups on a box and he
did it on a 20 inch box with a 45 pound
pack
working up to a thousand over a period
of time and then
once he got there then he would just
like pump out a thousand every couple
days
chad was super disciplined he was
incredibly focused in every goal that he
had and
and that's definitely something that i'm
trying to have live within me
this workout i talked about at his
funeral and so it more or less
organically kind of just became a thing
right dave was there crossfit friends
were there dave castro was there yeah
and they just did it on their own
just because they thought oh challenge
right that's cool thousands of pups 45
you know man stuff let's do it and
then fast forward i'll i'll stop you
there i won't speak for dave but i will
say
i mean dave knew chad they served they
served together and
he doesn't know how to process that you
know i mean he doesn't know how to
process the loss of a friend especially
to suicide and so
you know he's trying to do
it is amazing how many people want to
help how many people this has affected i
mean chad's life ripple effects huge but
everybody has this
there's some this
this epidemic has touched so many people
and nobody knows how to deal with it
nobody knows how i mean am i supposed to
do 22 push-ups in front of my you know
phone and publish it on social media i
mean is that helping
22 is not the number
right it's not even an accurate number
yeah it's 17. it's 17 now which is which
is better
you know it's just so many people want
to want to help so i think
you know dave for his part i mean i know
he he wanted to to honor chad and
you know i think he wanted other people
to honor chad as well
and and that's
yeah
uh
so so we've established chad 1000x into
an annual fundraiser
and
there there are many spouses like myself
gold star spouses and they've gone on
and there's golf tournaments and there's
5ks and there's the like and they raise
monies for different organizations this
workout specifically we want around
veterans day because while it's chad's
face
and i
have kind of stepped into the the role
of sharing his story
for me
it has less to do
with with chad wilkinson and more to do
about the struggle
that our veterans currently have and so
why not
really focus this around veterans day
when that's what we're doing honoring
those serving
and create a platform for them to talk
to one another
we did this last year and it was kind of
a late roll out and we're like let's
just like do this and see what happens
and very
we really had no expectation and i can't
even express how
humbled we were
by
the response and i mean it it went
global it went around the world people
people did this work out
i think the beauty of it is
anybody can do this workout because a
step up is not technical we're not
snatching there's no muscle ups that you
know
anybody can do a step up
and then obviously we scale it and you
know you have this huge fitness
background you're well aware not
everyone has to do the 20-inch box not
everybody has to do that weight
but being able to
go do
a workout
in honor of someone in our military that
that generally brings people together
anyway because they want to kind of pay
their humble respects
but the potential
that it could bring
for people to have a conversation
whether it's you're doing the step ups
and maybe you start to realize in that
hour time frame where your brain does go
what do you think about
you know
your struggle
the person you're doing it for the
friend you lost
do you do it with a friend
and you guys can talk to each other
well i think jason and i have confirmed
that once you get to probably about 500
you don't really talk anymore
but
the idea of doing it with a friend
the symbolism there is to me everybody
needs somebody
have you put together a technical
question here have you put together like
a ramp up program for people to do
you know
two months out do
a hundred
and then whatever break it down like you
know those marathon programming things
where yeah there's yeah there's a
training program yeah
yeah and so you know part of the the
bigger message here is
you know
i've never met the guy that i served
with ever who said man i'm really
looking forward to going to that
shrink's office with the waterfall in
the background and it's really quiet and
let's go talk about feelings
right i've never met that i've never met
that person right especially from our
community
well
have you heard a night go
chad went okay do you want to know how i
feel about it
sure
i mean i've i i've talked to a lot of
guys that went to it that thought it was
awesome
and i don't know when chad went december
2016 and within two years he was dead
they found seven tbis on his brain and
they laughed
what do you mean
that wasn't very many one of the guys we
were with had 42. he made a joke he said
yeah i got to walk around with a
football helmet because i can't risk
falling over
the guy you know i mean they can joke
among each other but it's just like
seven tbis to them wasn't very many but
you know what you can't find on all
those screens cte or interface astro
glow scarring
so
it you know i am a i am an advocate of
whatever you find works if that works
for you do it
100 i believe it feel it live it
but
i i am not convinced by any military
centered
organization
that they're really doing
any sort of good yet
and i don't know if they just want to
talk about it
and not be about
it by less than two years later chad was
dead and you know you do all the things
i mean there there is a lot of
assessment that happens at that place
and could be potentially good
um
it told me almost all the things i
already knew about him
as a spouse
i are you know they did personality
tests and and
different stress tests and i mean yes i
don't know the scientific sleep lab
study but i could tell you his sleep is
[ __ ]
um
they did a test where they are trying to
realize are you the guy
that's gonna
i'm trying to think of the best way they
said this basically are you the guy
that's gonna see a problem and respond
right away like rapid fire like bull in
a china shop are you the guy that's
going to like take a minute assess it
and you're not going to be very fast but
it's going to be methodical and it's
going to be perfect well that's chat if
you would have ever watched him pack a
car for a family trip that's chad so all
the things that they did there
you know i don't feel like it gave
me any more insight than i already had
and i'm not so sure
that's the case
for chad i mean and they do art therapy
and they do dog therapy and they do
music therapy
and i mean even them making him walk a
dog he finally said to him hey man
i'll do whatever you want me to do but
i'm not walking this damn dog
he's probably one of the few team guys
that like he didn't like dogs
um
so
yeah if it works for people and they got
something out of it great but the way i
see it is it's a way for the guys to go
fat in their medical records so they can
punch the ticket on where their medical
disability lies which
to be totally frank as a spouse every
single one of those dudes should be 100
disabled
yeah no i
i never went to it it wasn't i don't
think it was it was in existence maybe
but i never went to it but i i do know a
lot of guys that went through it that
got a lot out of it and part of what
they got out of it yeah they're looking
at their medical record but you know
they're i mean just the
the decompression aspect of it meaning
for 30 days like you're just gonna eat
nice food and
like not
do anything not blow anything up or
whatever
there was and and guys felt i i
definitely know some guys that got a lot
out of going to it uh clearly um there's
some shortfalls um
especially if they find issues and
they're like oh yeah this is no factor
that seems kind of crazy but yeah you
mentioned that cte thing because they
can't they they can't see cte
while you're alive right it's postmortem
so same thing interface obstacle is
growing right now there is no test for
it
so
to some degree
those guys out there that have served
multiple deployments and know you have
some tbis
you might want to almost assume that
that could be in there
what
what i think could be a great way and an
extension of service for some of our
military is this keiko form we fill out
before the guys deploy and um for
listeners it's it's
it's
it's a form we fill out that basically
says what's going to happen should your
husband get killed or or wife your
spouse gets killed and everything from
who's going to show up at your door are
they going to wear their uniform is it
military honors are they buried are they
cremated who's going to take your kids
all those
you know pretty important questions it's
kind of sad that when you fill it out so
many times it's commonplace i remember
the first time i filled it out we mold
over these questions for so long and
and by the end of the deployments i mean
i'm like making dinner and i'm like oh
yeah that's fine yep that's fine wait
change that because she moved and she's
not going to be able to get here in time
so make it this person i mean that's how
it is
but
and there's there is some there is
going to be some limitations and i don't
know what they are but we were able to
donate chad's brain
because he he was stateside and you have
to do it probably within 48 to 72 hours
i'm not quite sure what the time frame
is and his brain was studied and that's
how we were able to determine that that
he did have that
and i don't know if it would be
applicable if you're overseas because of
travel time etc but if you were to add
that on the keiko form that if you were
killed you would like your brain donated
this is a no way to encourage
anybody to take their life
by any means
but
either way if you're a team guy and and
you get in a car accident and you die
fill in the blank
if you could also put on there or at
least have a conversation with your
person
that you also want your brain donated
that would be a great extension of
service
i think that's a straightforward ask i
mean and yeah the straightforward ask
brain study is kind of a big it's a big
topic in in those circles right now and
there
there's so many elements that go into
this
but you know there's
the two places where the brains really
being studied right now are china and
japan
and europe you know there's just
protests on chimpanzees excuse me and so
you know because they're the closest to
us the best way to study the brain is
while it's working
you know you can't
make sense right right and so
you know we have
issues doing that here with chimpanzees
you know they're they're chasing off
the european equivalent of peta's
chasing off you know scientists from
europe they're they're just setting up
shop in china and it's like yeah we're
gonna we're gonna graph this brain you
know and
so there's a lot of there's a lot of
challenges that we will we will face
what what we do know
is that mass veteran suicide is not a
thing
guys don't all get together and kill
themselves at the same time we need we
need to create
communities with with bonds of people
that were able to take some of the
lessons that that sarah's
bravely sharing with us and and so many
behind or behind and around her
are sharing about their journey what
they've seen we need to strengthen the
community so that we're able to kind of
watch after
each other because the military has a
stronger social fabric than pretty much
anywhere
and
in in sort of normal you know
middle america or anywhere america right
and and still
you're you're 1.5 there's a lot of
different statistics but you're 1.5
times more likely to take your life if
you're in the military than if you're
not
and it's just you know how is this
happening like how is this okay well
it's not okay
and so what we're trying to do and what
we are doing is bringing people together
in the real world not in the shrinks
office with the waterfall you know that
you don't want to be there and it's like
hey you know physical health
mental health somehow those are
definitely we don't have to study
chimpanzees to know that those are
definitely tied together and obviously
chad did not suffer from physical
you know like he could do a thousand
step ups just fine and climb mountains
and stuff but you know all these things
you know you're not sleeping well great
work out you know you talk about this
all the time jocko right
you know
and and so bring people together yes
think about this and so it was really
telling when we did this in virginia
beach and guys that chad had served with
showed up you know quietly kind of did
the work you know they showed up in the
big f-950s that you know it's like
just awesome this is america god bless
us right
and uh you know they showed up and if if
this was a group counseling session to
talk about you know the mandatory briefs
no way nobody's showing up for that
stuff
but you show up and and you do the work
in honor of you know to honor chad's
life and to think about veteran suicide
prevention to think about this
unbreakable guy right i mean go ask
anybody in the navy that go wants to be
a seal do you want chad's career they're
like yes that's i want that to be me
and you got guys showing up and you know
there there's some community around it
you know everyone's then bending sarah's
ear that's that's you know because this
issue is so close to
so close to so many people in the
community
and
but you're just strengthening bonds
right you bring people together in the
real world this is very counter culture
and we're very cool with that you know
in a world where kids are growing up
text messaging each other to instead of
talking instead of sitting captain
kneecap like like we are right now right
and we need this we're social animals
and we need to be
a part of something bigger than
ourselves and so that's that's what
we're about and and
physical health and mental health and
raising awareness and it's
it can't just be
you know
trying to beat it into people right like
oh i'm a hammer i see a nail let me just
tell let me tell you about veteran
suicide prevention people just tune that
out but when you've got a story as you
got a story like chaz and you got some
like sarah that's that's able and
willing to tell it i mean this is hard
she's gotta she's gotta saddle up every
time
every time for this and she's doing it
because she wants to change the number
and she wants other people to not go
through what she's had to go through and
there's there's a lot of bravery that
goes
that goes into that and
you know and so that's i'm i'm proud
that that we get to i mean i work for
her in this goruck works for her and you
know we don't do anything that that
she's not on board with in terms of
chad's story or just the way that we're
running the running the event around and
you know we just have
this is just a unique opportunity in in
the kind of veteran suicide prevention
space that that nobody wants to be too
close to but unfortunately
you know some of us are and and um so
it's a real honor this is this is the
thing i'm most proud of that i've been a
part of because it is it's just it's
it's
it's changing lives it's helping people
and bringing them together and raising
awareness for something that is is
really important to me because i know i
know you've lost there's people in your
circle i'm sure people in my circle
there's you know you know there's sarah
sitting right there i mean this is this
is her life
and so
it just this is this matters this
matters hugely to us
well i'm on board um like what do people
need to do when they're on board what
are we doing what's what's our deal
well
we
we want people to take to the workout
and that might look
different for a lot of people you can go
to your local gyms
jump on it do it in your garage find a
buddy we're hosting larger scale what we
call live events this year and we're
doing those in some we'll call like
flagship cities one of them's here in
san diego so we're hoping maybe you
might come and show up right on november
6 uh san diego it'll be at crossfit
humanity
so not too far from here i passed it
actually on the way
we're doing it november 13th well let me
back up november 5th we're going to be
doing it in fort pierce florida at the
udt seal museum so
it's their stump muster weekend i'll be
speaking and doing some other things
down there so place is outstanding if
you get a chance go to fort pierce
florida and visit the udtc museum it's
awesome it it is it is really really
cool um
so that's november 5th november 6 we're
in san diego november 11th is going to
be new york city november 13th is going
to be virginia beach uh my hometown and
jack's jacks is actually november 6th
now oh is it going to be moved a little
bit earlier yeah so we're hosting so you
know call it a big giant muster start
start getting your your train on you got
a thousand box steps with a 45 pound
ruck bro
that's a get some evolution right that's
a get some evolution right there
evolution
that is a get some evolution for sure
you know he used to do that i don't know
if you know this but he used to do it in
the garage i have video of this him
doing step ups and he would do it in you
know in the garage and just shorts in
his backpack he cut all the tags out of
his gear right ounces equal pounds sarah
ounces equal pounds so he knew he was
carrying but he used a projector and he
projected aconcagua on the back of our
garage door
so when i talk about focus
[Music]
that's how focused he was and that's
that's how focused i am with this
so and then and then what we're raising
money is that what we're doing we are
raising money okay so um this this came
about through a partnership that goruck
had had with the navy seal foundation
awesome you know one of your brothers
chris irwin who was sarah was his level
one crossfit instructor in virginia
beach way back when i mean you know
everyone is so close close to everyone
and
he he had called me and and said hey you
know because did you ever teach any any
of these ones out here on the west coast
uh i taught some in del mar yeah i think
i probably went to two or three of those
over the years okay in that time frame
too yeah yeah i'm sure we crossed paths
and that yeah i was the guy with the
massive deadlift notice
yeah no you would not remember me from
my physical attributes at a crossfit
seminar
yeah so we're raising money so we're
raising money and you know this this
came about through that partnership and
and uh you know chris had called me up
and he was like you know
nobody knows how to deal with this man
everyone wants to deal with it and
nobody knows how to deal with it
and and
he you know so you get guys that are in
positions you're at the seal foundation
and goruck whatever right it's like we
we want to deal with this we still
didn't know how to deal with it and he's
like well i think i got
i think this chad workout is the way
that we can deal with this
he goes but i got to call sarah because
obviously you know you don't do anything
without the family if the family's not
on board especially the spouse i mean
spouse is the that that's the
that's the deal
and you know she had to think about it
and you know said no and then thought
about it and we ended up chatting it was
me and emily and and chris and
sarah nicole i'm out you know it's
florida we have you know it's hot i'm
outside my kids are inside pure chaos
we're chatting on zoom or whatever it
was in the middle of the pandemic and
she's finally like okay let's do this
and i'm like i kind of said okay well
you know if you change your mind she's
like no i've made up my mind we're doing
this right
and so to to throw her another
like crossfit there's a lot of hard
workouts in crossfit right a lot of you
can look at you know you can do them
harder you can scale them to whatever
the the hardest
the hardest workout in the history of
crossfit that's ever been done
was how she did chad the first time
she went into into their garage and she
put on chad's rucksack by herself and
did chat
so think about that when you're feeling
sorry for yourself out there you know
because it's a hard workout and it is
right and that's what it's supposed to
be everyone's selling easy that that's
you don't think about anything
when when life's easy except the next
easy thing you're gonna get right you're
you're meant to dig deep you're meant to
think about this and and that's
that's the goal and so raising money
uh half of it's going to the seal
foundation
sarah has a nonprofit called the step up
project and and that's um you know it's
it's veteran mental health stuff it's
all going to support that
yeah well that's outstanding um
and you know i have to throw this out
there because like uh earlier you
we we were talking in the middle of
whatever uh some high emotion moments
and you said something about the
the
families right and i just i
i thought about it but then you know we
kept talking but just the fact that
the military family's out there and what
they put up with and what they go
through and usually i mean in my mind
have to worry more than the people that
are in the military themselves
so
on on top of all this just uh
you know the families that are out there
that the the um
the spouses you know um come on down too
because
like it just get to know other people
that are living that life
uh you know i know that my my wife you
know she wasn't around we didn't have
any family around like we didn't have
any family we lived in california when
we lived in virginia beach i was gone
almost the entire time she
didn't know anyone she ended up doing
what you did which is going to live with
my parents for a while
but yeah just families right military
families too come and get it that's what
i'm thinking
family-friendly kid friends we don't
discriminate come on down all of them it
was it was so awesome in virginia beach
it was such a great vibe you know we
were there at the
crack of dawn right setting boxes up and
then
you know
it's like all of a sudden people start
to show up in waves because you need a
box right so there's waves of people
getting on the box and people i mean we
were there my flight was late that that
afternoon and you guys are still
you know there was still a big crew
there just like social it was social and
so it's not a depressing
you know it's not it's not like you you
just people can't live inside that space
forever right you have you you have your
your difficult moments and you think
about it and it's hard
but you know
anybody anybody
that that served the way that chad
served like the guys i served with you
don't want people to walk around
depressed
after you're gone you want them you you
don't want that i also think uh like a
lot of
uh i i just think the more we do talk
about it the easier it is for someone
else to say
me too
and
so
it's hard to come out and talk about
this all the time and i've had i've this
week has been a very busy week for me so
i'm pretty
it's been hard but
i have to believe that the more i talk
about it and share chad's story or or
share the story of of other friends that
have passed
took their lives
that other people will start to speak up
at this virginia beach event i had three
people separately pull me aside
and confide in me struggles that they
had i've had people reach out to me
through social media like long messages
i don't care i don't care how long it is
i don't care how short it is and i
respond back
and i i think that it's slow and i think
it's a trickle but the potential for
this workout done around veterans day so
we can talk about people's stories so
that it might encourage someone else to
say me too
maybe all if all they need to hear is
that they're not alone and that someone
else feels that too maybe that's what
someone needs and that's great yeah
that's
i
when you know what's happening
it makes things so much easier
and i i i talk about this like you get a
new guy like jason you get a new guy
that looks really nervous before their
first operation
and if you go hey bro here's what's
going on you're nervous it's cool you're
a little queasy your stomach's a little
messed up yeah because they're they're
scared they're nervous and if you go
yeah that's normal it's just no big deal
you're going to feel that that way a
little bit before you go on an ops no
big deal don't worry about it that's
your body preparing to go into combat
it's all good and you can see like
relief on their face that's mentorship
right there yeah yeah and we need more
of that
yeah
and this to me this this whole thing is
like if you can tell someone oh
yeah you you've breached 47 doors in
your last three week trip which is not
an extraordinary number like that that's
you know oh you you got crashed in a
room however many times you shot a carl
gustav
29 times you or you were the ra the rso
so you had
you know two troops go through and shoot
one per man and you ran you rso'd all of
them
that's
whatever you know 80 freaking blasts
next to your head that you sat through
and
there are some things that are going on
inside your brain here's what's going on
here's what you need to watch out for
here's how you can get ahead of it
that kind of conversation about this
stuff
is the same thing that it impacts that
young new guy that goes oh okay got it
now i can grab it now i can get a hold
of it and i can move
forward it's awesome
chad1000x.com
that's where we can go to find out about
this stuff um
go ruck you're at goruck across the
board across the board jason if you want
to talk to jason at go rock and just go
rock i if i live in uh
idaho can i do goruck yes what if i live
in nebraska
so look here's the thing we have we have
500 official goruck clubs around the the
country and and part of it is
we we're activating all of them for this
we really believe in this world of
people getting together in the real
world and this is not about you don't
have to be a veteran to do this you
don't have to be anything except willing
to show up right and you get so much out
of it and got through a freaking
thousand step ups just fyi
yeah it's an hour you know it's an hour
yeah right okay slow and steady slow and
steady wins the race yeah i mean yeah
and you want to train up yeah well
that's
maybe we need to release some kind of a
preparatory
workout i don't want a bunch of rap
though people are coming and coming at
me scale it you're worried about people
coming at you after for rabdo now come
on uh i've imposed rhabdo on a few
people and it it it doesn't feel good i
feel horrible you know i always feel
like
i i won't do it anymore i i kind of
figured it out like it just
it it's not i don't like doing that to
people no no we same thing so disclaimer
is you need to train yourself up this is
an hour it's it's step ups yeah yeah
yeah you got this step ups with a 45
pound plate on your back
yeah scale it down if you're not right
we need to train but we need to train
for it right yes that's what i'm saying
so it's it's a buy-in for your your
workouts it's it's a cash out for your
workouts whatever else you're doing just
just integrate a box if you've got a
cooler in your house use a cooler if
there's you know like whatever the case
may be you have steps yep
get it uh
instagram you're on instagram yes sarah
wilkinson seven
number seven yep
jason you got anything else did i miss
anything
i don't think so
did we miss anything
oh well i guess just to bring just to
make the point one more time and is that
where we find the guys are very fragile
i'm gonna say fragile is in their
transition time so when people are
separating from the military maybe they
didn't hit retirement maybe they've done
10 years and they're transitioning out
or they're at retirement and now they
need to
transition to civilian life that is a
very
for a seal i'm going to say that's a
very delicate time for them
and
i would encourage families
peers to really be on the lookout for
them during that time
because
as we've talked so much about the brain
and ptsd there's also that loss of of
tribe
or at least they feel as though there is
and
what we see is sometimes that increases
the likelihood of
maybe someone not making a really good
decision so
i would just encourage people to
just be of the best support for those
people during that period of transition
yeah interestingly that's when uh
that's when a seal platoon is most
exposed when they're transitioning from
the water to the land or the land to the
water and there's not only a perceived
loss of tribe like you're talking about
but also that perceived loss of mission
because
what have i been doing my whole life and
all of a sudden what am i going to do
now
yeah when chad um
when chad was close to 20 years we were
at the discussion of what do we do you
know my dad served 26 years his dad
served
somewhere about that i can't quite
remember and
uh
you know the hard part is i i really
kind of hoped he would pick us
i thought okay we've done 20 years like
we've done 20 years me sarah chad
kinsley hudson we've done it boom pick
us
and he didn't
um
and i again believe he had a warrior's
heart and he was born to do this
but
i said to him well you know we talked
about jobs and i just remember he looked
at me and he said i don't have any
skills
that's what they think i mean he was
dead serious and you're thinking what i
mean i know that you're not gonna go
work for someone and be hanging out in
bushes and kicking down doors most
likely
but
what the skills these guys do have i
mean
most of them are are very intelligent
critical thinkers analytical
problem solvers think outside of the box
can make decisions quickly
that is a lot of really great attributes
that
many
organizations in the civilian world
would want and so
again just to speak to
i i you know it's that loss of identity
and it's like i've been shooting guns
and busting down doors
what else do i do
one of my first platoon chiefs said he
there was a old vietnam seal
and he was a mailman now
and they would go over there and like
drink beer or whatever at his house and
he'd tell stories about nam nice
and he had this
picture on the wall and it was uh like a
shop from behind like a picture of of a
guy's back and the guy's the guy who's
back you see is clearly a vietnam seal
with a floppy hat and a stoner and his
web gear on and his jungle cami top and
his blue jeans and he's standing in
front of like a corporate desk
and the
the corporate desk there's the boss guys
looking at him and the caption
underneath this i'm sorry sir we don't
have any jobs for point men here
which is true but to your point and
believe me i see this all the time i
work with companies all over the country
and all over the world actually and they
absolutely need the individuals that
have these kind of attributes that
you're talking about and there is
absolutely a new mission when you get
done with the military to go out in the
civilian world and have an impact make
people's lives better and build great
products and build great companies and
and do great things
and that is absolutely available and you
are needed in the in the civilian world
and that's the way it is we need them
too
like our country needs
people with this kind of experience
spread throughout our our country spread
throughout our companies spread
throughout our communities spread
throughout our our neighborhoods and one
of the things that makes san diego such
a great town is it's it's a military
there's it's a military town you've got
this just
underpinnings of san diego the
foundation is strong it's the same where
i live in jacksonville beach i mean my
my neighbor two doors down as a top gun
instructor i mean these things are just
normal
around
us and it's great they're just good
people that are just you know this
talk about you know the greatest
generation coming back to america and
just doing great stuff getting educated
and working their asses off and building
america into america and
you know we need more of that and so we
need we need the transition is is it's
to echo her point i mean it's it's just
sucks i mean don't underestimate it
under any circumstances it can't happen
to you it will happen to you it will be
terrible
and and just now that you know it's
coming brace for it a little bit take it
easy on yourself build out some support
structures around you
you know stuff like that and we just
this is going to require something that
is not
kind of
normal this day and age it's going to
require us to kind of work together
you know
like how to support
transitioning folks better how to kind
of build stronger communities in the
real world
how to like that's what we need we don't
we you don't need guys coming out and
it's like hey you know what you need to
do you need to be an influencer on
instagram
right like no
you know how about not that
right and and so you know it's it's it's
difficult it's difficult and and
we have to keep having the conversation
that's why i i respect you and then and
i respect this long form
um podcast stuff that you do because
it's it's it forces people you know it's
not just sound bites it's like hey
here's the story this is nothing's as
simple as as it looks on someone's feed
and
you know
that's kind of what real life is like
and i think that we we need more of that
not less
totally agree well speaking of long form
i've kept you in here for over three
hours um
jason thank you for what you're doing
thanks for your service you know we
covered that last time
uh and thanks for what you're continuing
to do build and go ruck and forming
communities out there
real communities i can see this look in
your eye when you when you start saying
that and and i get it man and for me
it's a lot through jiu jitsu but look
that that's a real thing and getting
people together to get together and
sweat and work
it's a positive thing man i appreciate
what you're doing and sarah obviously
thanks for coming on
thanks for your service thanks for your
sacrifice um thanks for holding the line
and
while your husband was gone and gone
again and gone again and and being there
and raising a family and building a
business and doing all those things
um
the all the military families that are
listening right now for what you go
through
and and what they risk
[Applause]
so
thanks to you thanks to your kids as
well for what they've gone through and
of course
chad um
thanks for your service bro
we won't forget
amen thank you
and with that
sarah wilkinson and jason mccarthy have
left the building
and
echo charles uh
we need to go a little bit old school i
think on this one for
the decompress
right so if
you've never listened to this before
the original
purpose of
when we would get done with a podcast
echo charles and i would just kind of
start talking about stuff for a little
while it was to
decompress from a heavy subject
as we started doing podcasts and started
hitting some heavy subjects along the
way this
we would originally just kind of start
talking and i would just kind of let
echo talk for a little bit while i did
the decompression because i'm usually
the one that's all wrapped up in
whatever subject
is we're talking about so
certainly uh
in need of a little decompression after
that one
um just a
just a very tough subject
and and that's why we're talking about
it right we're talking about it
as
you know sarah said like something that
she doesn't want anyone else to have to
go through
and
[Music]
that's why we talk about these things um
so for a little decompressing um i'll
let you talk a little bit echo charles
we
we want people to take care of
themselves it's true so you you
like it's weird because so there's so
many mysteries to the brain
right so and with your body like your
physical your other part parts of your
body it's like less of a mystery right
so like yeah you go in you know you're
in a combat scenario you get shot in the
abdomen
then it's like okay it's going to be
pretty straightforward as far as hey can
we save this guy can we not you know all
this stuff and like he can bleed out he
can there's all these things and then
there's these you know you can take
specific actions and then hopefully we
can save them all this stuff
you get shot in the leg or something
while you're running or you blow out
your knee or something it's like okay
it's broken he can't run anymore it's
like pretty straightforward but the
brain gets damaged in one way or another
it's kind of like there's no telling
what's going to happen a lot of the time
you know and you don't know when either
it's it's it is the brain is the
mysterious
part of the anatomy right now and nerves
right yeah i don't really know how they
work it's very hard to like repair them
yeah and and then
yeah as we said you take that brain and
rattle around inside of a inside of your
skull over and over again
we don't know what it's going to do but
we know it's not good we know that yeah
and then you have to make it kind of in
a way work okay remember kirsty ennis
yes right so she she got jammed up she
got injured and she's still at her leg
you know she was she was doing this
thing and then but she was constantly
being checked in upon you know checked
on and be like okay and then over time
they were like hey okay we're at a point
where we got to make this very specific
decision and we know what could and you
know all the stuff and it was pretty it
was pretty clear and then you make the
decision but that's that's an example of
incurring an injury and then it's still
having lasting effects lasting effects
until you gotta you know either
risk actually dying or risk huger and
bigger injuries or just say chop it off
or amputate and you know remember her
talking about
she knows she because she could still
walk yeah
yeah and she was taking her last walk on
the beach in the sand yeah exactly right
but a perfect example of like you can
incur the injury
and still handle still
you know go about your business sure you
jammed up here and there here and there
and then but the injury is still
progressing yeah it's getting worse it's
getting worse
and then you get and meanwhile but the
thing is again for your your other parts
of your body it's kind of like there's
kind of a protocol you can check in and
be like okay for the brain it's so
mysterious it's like we can try and we
are kind of trying to do that but it's
so mysterious that it's not as cut and
dry like that and it's the same exact
thing he incurred all these injuries
at some point and that thing just keeps
lasting and lasting getting worse and
worse and worse you know until it it
gets you
but it's crazy it's hard to get like get
a grip on exactly what's happening
it's crazy though it's the unknown
frontier of the human body probably the
most unknown
frontier of the human body yeah
the nerves in the brain and there's so
many illusions too even like with
yourself where you can be like i'd
i'd just do this in this situation or
that situation or i would never choose
to do that but you get in a certain like
situation you do some stuff that's real
unexplainable
or only explainable later even though
you thought from before like beforehand
you were you were so convinced of
something and then afterwards you're
like oh she all surprised on what you
did you know kind of thing so it's like
so there's this big illusion like it's
like oh yeah he could just make the
decision not to or whatever but it's
like that doesn't work like that
lots of factors come into play yeah
i don't know
well um
we do want people to
like i said want people to take care of
themselves yeah and the ones around them
and the ones around them but we gotta
kind of like the analogy goes with the
the plane and the oxygen got to put the
oxygen on your own face before you put
it on your kids it's true so um so you
got to do a little something to kind of
keep yourself in the game sarah
mentioned something where he said oh i
don't have any skills right and he was
talking about getting a job or something
like this and i was thinking yeah you
know i can see why someone might think
that off like for at first but the fact
is you have a lot of skills and one of
the main skills is straight up
capability
in all these different ways where you
know you can learn this specific thing
or learn that specific trade and all
this uh other stuff but if someone who's
just a more capable person across the
board that guy's gonna excel in those
skills for sure
so
in my opinion that's an important thing
to be capable and to stay capable
so on this path of capability hopefully
we're going to take some hits some
heavies it happens
that's the that's kind of like you
mentioned jiu jitsu and jiu jitsu if
you're going hard
are you not going to get dinged up no
you are going to get yeah that's kind of
the nature of going hard see i'm saying
just like in workouts just like with
anything else but don't worry
supplementation will help us all
through those dings
dents
so anyway chocolate supplements
it's a long way of saying jacqueline
supplements
so first thing we're going to do we're
decompressing a little bit let me
chuckle a little bit a little bit we're
trying over here decompression okay yeah
so jaco has a new era of energy drinks
straight up healthy for you i know we
don't equate health and energy drinks in
the same thing didn't used to no we do
know we do now new era discipline go
many different flavors
best flavor is mango
kind of by far imagine that
your own activities and that's saying a
lot because the orange is freaking good
yeah you know the sour like these are
like good flavor they taste good but
like mango is just so much better it's
like crazy it's saying a lot see i'm
saying yeah um
the good thing is that these drinks they
taste different you you gotta some
people might not like mango probably a
small number of people
some people might not like orange some
people not might not like sour apple
sniper some people might not like jocko
palmer some people might not like
whatever
so
the recommendation is trial try one see
what you like yeah let me know but
let echo charles know if his
signature flavor is the best well it
since it's factually the best you love
your flavor the best i like will you
ever drink another different kind yes
yeah i do okay see that's what's weird
only because i don't want to drink them
all and i won't have any i got to call
pete and brian in them and you know
there's that but if you had all flavors
in a fridge
every for one year yeah i can do one
near you and i was restocking yours
would i ever have to replace a sour
apple sniper
you would never have to know here's the
thing i could do one year but in the
spirit of you know
nature and all that stuff like if you're
eating steak every single night uh-huh
and someone offers you that off the path
of the of the mango mayhem in the spirit
of variety yes okay for sure well that's
you know that's that i think that's
natural i'm pretty sure yeah i would
only drink chocolate palmer i understand
because it tastes so good to me
yeah
but i also only eat steak so there you
go see because you're different all
right well either way either way so we
got a drink is what you're saying it
doesn't matter what flavor you choose to
drink at any particular time regardless
if mango's the best
flavor
it's all healthy for you so you're
drinking the energy drink you get in the
front end the energy
the little boost
that we sometimes want boom but you get
the health benefits as well yeah as
opposed to the poison benefits or lack
of benefits or what are the detriments
you understand what i'm saying either
way discipline go you can get this
wawa mm-hmm vitamin shop yep amazon
yeah
and originusa.com also we have
jackoffield.com
jackalfuel.com but jaclyn feels it
easier to remember yeah that's the
direction for the fuel you don't got to
click around all that stuff um also got
joint warfare this is for your joints
when you're lifting hard you're doing
jiu jitsu like you don't want to worry
about the joints if you don't want to
worry about your joints this is the one
that that we need i don't want to worry
about joints it's going to be pretty
rare you're going to want to worry about
your joints but i don't know some people
are more in touch with that kind of
stuff and that's cool too either way
joint wherever and super krill oil will
make sure that they're still in the game
longevity man hey have you had the
greens yet
no well we
have greens now oh right now and decide
to come up with a creative name all
right what is it jocko greens
we made some
very good greens and uh so you can check
those out too if you if you don't eat
enough vegetables like me or fruits like
me yeah
now you can
in a scoop yeah
yeah that's good and and again you know
true jackal style apparently
you're making these things taste good
yeah which is very not hardcore review
by the way but it is very efficient and
what it's all it's real low drag it's
also results related
not trying to get you to drink something
that tastes like junk yeah
and then you don't drink it because it
tastes like junk yeah why would we do
that you're not trying to offer up
another element of resistance
in a good path that we're all on yeah
yeah it's true that's a good move um
also vitamin d3 cold war immunity stuff
this is essential so don't forget about
that kind of stuff also milk we talked
about steaks i get it but sometimes you
want extra dessert
back on the strawberry path right now
you are going hardcore strawberry for
like a week and a half i was going
hardcore peanut butter for at least a
month what's the what's your normal pro
are you putting anything in there in the
little banana little whatever what are
you just straight
monk and some variety of milk
could be coconut milk
could be
uh almond milk it could be the oat milk
could be the milk milk but yeah mix it
up with one of those yeah and they all
taste legit they all have their own
little
you know yeah you want to know my
protocol watch i've been freaking on and
it's freaking solid and it tastes good i
don't know though so is it normal like
what do you let's say you had a salad
like not like a side salad but a
robust
salad you know
steak salad chicken salad whatever what
do you drink with that what's the norm
what pairs with that that i don't i know
you're gonna say water i know okay
what's the jam you don't want me to say
water all right well water kind of goes
with everything you always get at the
restaurant they're gonna give you the
water first so that's a given but what
is you know what's the jam your story
your your thing is not going anywhere so
where are you going with this okay i
drink water here's what i pair with a
big salad it's called the big salad
chicken very robust salad um
milkshake
but just a plain one though
plain like not usually add a banana a
frozen banana in there or whatever no no
whatever so i i'll go the peanut butter
peanut butter chocolate and then milk or
the almond milk or whatever just you
know you don't add the
oatmeal or bananas or whatever if you
want to make it all luxury or whatever
it's insane but it like pairs nicely
right on i like it all right well either
way these things again
jackalful.com yeah um subscribe if you
want the influx you know where you don't
gotta remember to reorder or run out and
all that stuff you don't have to
remember you don't have to pay shipping
oh yeah those are two real solid
elements
it's true
so we mentioned origin usa
dot com
this is where you can get your
american-made denim yep
kind of a big deal no it's a real big
deal yeah when you kind of go down the
line it's like sure you're getting good
genes i get it that's that's good it's
great actually
or something crazy when we first looked
into making these jeans
we were talking to people
we were talking to people in the fashion
industry legit
yeah i understand you know which they
wanted us to charge for a pair of jeans
american-made jeans you know what the
value placed on american 100
american-made jeans was take a guess how
much
118. i'm not kidding you they said the
good market price
450 for a pair of jeans this was like in
new york city with fashion
and i like kicked pete under the table
like right charging 450 dollars for a
pair of jeans no that's not happening no
and we walked out i'm like that's not a
music it's not happening he said calm
down you know i was kind of losing it
because we know i already don't like
fashion people in the first place now
they want me to
charge 450 because they're trying to
they're trying to keep the control of
the market right they're trying to keep
that thing elevated because they want to
charge 450 for their pair of jeans yeah
but you know the whole idea of charging
that much for jeans like whatever
they're doing there like it's not a
matter of like hey we gotta you know and
it makes this logistical sense it's not
that they're doing something oh no
they're inflating the prices yeah for a
reason like they're doing what's their
thing what are they doing like that
thing i think i'll tell you what they're
doing they know that people want to buy
american-made stuff they know they can't
make it they want us to price it out of
the market so they have to worry about
that's what they are doing that makes
sense when i'm playing their games well
the good news is it doesn't cost
459.99 whatever you said so boom there
you go you also got boots on there yep
by the way same american-made 100
bringing back the industry by the way
expanding like geez louise
as far as cheese louise goes
bro i'm saying there's a uh there's a
lot going on
deadlifting she's getting jacked that's
what's happening with
yes sir
um but yes so origin usa there's a lot
of cool stuff jujitsu's stuff on there
as well yeah you get that ghee yeah you
get to give you're getting back into
jiu-jitsu where you get you're staying
in jiu-jitsu you want another gui okay
good community
awesome good community jiu jitsu also
community yeah that's true
also we have a store it's called jocko
store so boom if you're on the path you
want to represent discipline equals
freedom good
take the high ground
or the high ground will take you
that's where you can use shirts and
hoodies and hats and whatnot some shorts
on there
utility
surfing swimming cruising
lifting jujit i said it all of it
everything they're what hybrid or
whatever
anyway i've got some shorts on there too
anyway
shorts with cargo pockets no
well you can't be wearing them for
swimming or jiu jitsu if they have the
pockets on them the big pockets for the
cargo
cargo pockets no you can have a little
cargo pocket on there not a freaking
baggy like from the gap store cargo
pocket from 1994. it does not have that
now
but the hand like the the pockets that
you stick your hands into on the front
you can't do jiu jitsu with those and
swimming's not recommended oh yes you
can
yes you can
okay
trust me you can well you might be able
to but it's not optimal yeah yeah well
maybe i'll put like zip can you put
zippers on them that would be make it a
little bit better we need to do uh a
pair of shorts with a
slim
pocket on the leg
no wait
and i think these already i don't have
to double check but they have like the
pocket is kind of it breathes like
through so the water can pass through
i'm wearing them right now they do have
that but that's still see
but you know what i'm doing right now
i'm working i'm pod they're good they're
excellent for podcasting yeah right yes
they're excellent for cruising for sure
yeah swimming is marginal because the
even though the water is made to drain
out of them it's still you're there's
big pockets holding water we're not
setting we're not swimming in the
english channel no yeah actually no no
thinking of it right so there's that and
then jiu-jitsu you're you know your toes
getting caught in there or whatever so
let's redesign
yes sir okay i thought we did redesign
uh well are we lagging we're working on
that one okay you know it's a work in uh
progress or whatever but
the good thing about this is if swimming
jiu-jitsu i know your toes get stuck in
there and it's true
but if they're not ideal because really
what's ideal for jiu-jitsu really it's
like spats on a rash guard same thing
we're swimming what's ideal for swimming
good olympics check it out that's what's
ideal for swimming okay a lot of us
sometimes we don't wear that kind of
stuff when we go swimming yeah some of
us i don't understand if we're not
swimming the english channel i get it we
can jump in the in the in the surf zone
if you
if if we're just cruising right now
and then we just find ourselves at the
beach i don't know we're like frick
let's go body surfing you can wear those
shorts is what i'm saying
yes and they're going to work great
they're going to be acceptable
very not optimal
they'll be appropriate how about that
now they're really good for normal life
yeah
which is what i wear them for boom but
if i'm going to roll i'm going to put on
a different pair of shorts that we need
to make jocko store.com
that's where you get all the stuff you
like something get something how about
that including but not limited to the
shorts right on um
subscribe to this podcast
if you want to
also have some other podcast jocko
unraveling
me and daryl cooper the grounded podcast
warrior kid podcast we also have that
underground
look we don't know what's gonna happen
with these platforms
so if something does happen these
platforms will be on jacounderground.com
if you want to subscribe to that it
helps us build it
eight dollars and eighteen cents a month
thanks for the support if you can't
afford it cool we'll support you
email assistants at
jockleunderground.com we have a youtube
channel
which there's a lot of high level
assistant directing happening on there
yeah very high level for sure
sarcasm
yeah actually i've accepted it
factually that yeah i dig it even like
with setup right you've been you know
you've come a long way you do some great
work so thank you but yeah the youtube
channel video version of this podcast
yeah also yeah by the way it's it's
becoming more and more common way
to consume as it were
yeah check that out origin usa also has
a little
uh youtube channel
that you can check out
it's true also
psychological warfare if you don't know
what that is it's an album with tracks
jocko getting you and me and us all past
our moments of weakness that to come
every once in a great while visitations
of moments of weakness
just saying it happens that's all i'm
saying so psychological warfare will
help you with that do i have to make a
psychological warfare track about foster
phobia
you know i had a question mark in my
head like should i even say that because
it's going to trigger you to start you
know talking to me about this kind of
stuff and maybe the answer is yes i
don't know but the current psychological
warfare where you can get wherever you
buy mp3s
that will help you with weaknesses that
it addresses check also
flipsidecanvas.com dakota meyer order
some cool stuff to hang on your wall got
a bunch of books
i just finished the audio version of
final spin which is the next book that i
have coming out i think it's coming out
uh november
sixth or something like that which i
just realized means i will not be
in this area for
the chad 1000x event
because i will be on the road
okay um i just recorded
i just recorded the audio book and it
was
the first time
that i got to see someone's reaction
live to the book because there was a
there was a worker there was a audio
engineer yeah yeah
she was named deb
she was in there working the working the
the
stuff
but here's what's freaking awesome this
is what this is what's fired up
there's funny parts in that book right
and she she's outside the glass right
i'm in the i'm in the room right
she's outside the glass and i'm watching
her and like i would read a funny line
and i can see her and she'd like laugh
and she'd be laughing and like looking
at me and like like nodding her head
and then there's a couple point parts in
the book that are kind of like fired up
like they're gonna go
and she was literally raising her hands
like i'd look at her she's like raise
your hand like
like they're gonna go
and then that was day one lots of setup
you know you could you kind of getting
to know the characters a little bit day
two stuff starts getting a little bit
going sideways
day two deb
openly weeping that i can visually watch
her cry
some parts of the
story that are heavy so
final spin if you want to know what
that's all about check it out dang
that's crazy that's like like she was
like your little audience i had an
audience of one yeah yeah and you know
what check this out she's supposed to be
a professional i know really right
disrespected she is a professional she
did a great job and i was much
appreciated she's not supposed to be in
there
laughing
cheering and crying right that's not
right yeah yeah hey
would you be stoked if your doctor's
doing a surgery on you like high-fiving
and laughing like no right
right you're gonna be stoked on that no
but i was definitely stoked yeah
it was
think about it it's like uh
you're right it was an audience on one
yeah and she's not supposed to be shown
emotions and she's in there getting
emotional all emotions revealed
so if you want to feel some of those
emotions hear about it i also did a
little
the additional uh the additional
commentary for the audio track
is with good deal dave burke because he
read it and he
interviewed me and we talked about it so
that's that
uh final spin check it out
pre-order it now if you want that first
to dish who knows with that kind of
emotional reaction you get that first to
dish you maybe hold on to something
special
hold
when they're old enough oh yeah i talked
to dave burke about that i'm like hey
would you let your
how old are you how old will your kids
have to be before they're allowed to
read this book and he's like
he's like i want him to read it as young
as i they can
but all there's swear words in it yeah
there's f-bombs quite a few
so he's like
he goes real soon yeah you know 13 14.
he said because the perspectives that it
gives a person on life so powerful that
he wants them to have it uh so that's
final spin leadership strategy and
tactics field manual the code the
evaluation the protocol discipline
equals freedom field manual brand new
versions out way the warrior kick two
three and four mikey and the dragons
hackworth about face and of course
extreme ownership and the dichotomy of
leadership that i wrote with my brother
lee fabin
we also have a consulting
company we solve
we solve problems through leadership
go to ashlandfront.com for details on
that if you want us to come and help
your company if you want to come to one
of our live events
the next muster is
in las vegas
october 28th and 29th so if you want to
come to that ftx september 20th and 21st
we're getting close might have already
passed that we also have an online
training
academy called extreme ownership extreme
ownership academy extremeownership.com
where you can learn leadership
and keep your leadership
edge sharp
if you want to help service members
active and retired their families gold
star families
i talked a little bit about the
hyperbaric chamber today
and that's one of the one of the things
that mama lee's charity organization
does is pay
for veterans to go into a city and stay
for like 30 days and get 30 days worth
of hyperbaric treatments that are so
helpful they're even helpful for these
kind of injuries that we talked about
today if you want to
donate or you want to get involved go to
america's mighty warriors dot org
and if you want more of my pathological
pauses
or you need more of echo's vacant
verbalizations
you can find us on the interwebs
on twitter on
the graham hello
on facebook
echo's adequate charles i am at
jacqueline and once again
for
chad
1000x go to chad1000x.com
if you want to check out sarah sarah's
instagram it's sarahwilkinson7
and then jason and everything that he's
doing
on goruck you want to find out where you
can get get involved in that it's a
really good stuff
check out
go ruck
and thanks once again to sarah wilkinson
and jason mccarthy for joining us today
and thanks to both of you for your
service
and thanks for
to both of you
for everything that you're doing today
to try and help raise awareness
and prevent suicide
straight up and all the veterans out
there
you've been through a lot
and
you start feeling like maybe you're in
that storm
remember that you can get out of that
storm ask for help get help
there's things that you've been exposed
to
that can
physiologically damage your brain
psychologically damage your brain that
can be fixed
so talk to someone
get help
if you need it please
and the same thing goes to police and
law enforcement firefighters out there
paramedics emts dispatchers correctional
officers border patrol
secret service all first responders
you live in a stressful environment you
get exposed to things that can damage
you
physiologically and psychologically if
you're feeling it
talk to somebody
and it's really the same thing for
everybody else out there
talk to people
there's no shame in asking for help you
don't have to face the darkness alone
hold on
ask for help
take another step
because there is light
and however dark it may seem in that
storm there is light
so take another step
and to chad
wilkinson thank you for your service
brother
and until next time
this is echo and jocko
out